İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar. 25 Kasım 2024 Pazartesi günü 42. ders günümüz saat 19.31 dersimize başlıyoruz.
Kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz. Ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin lütfen değerli arkadaşlar.
Efendim nerede kaldık nerede kaldık hemen hatırlıyoruz. Önce studvektör konteynerını jenerik sınıfını gördük. Ara ara yine vektörle ilgili bazı noktalara geri döneceğiz.
Aslında ikinci konteynerımıza başlayacaktık studdeck fakat ondan önce biraz da algoritmalara bakalım dedik ve sıralamayla ilgili sorting related algoritm sıralamayla ilgili bir şekilde sıralamayla ilgisi olan algoritmaları incelemeye başladık.
Arkadaşlar burada epey bir algoritma var. Şöyle bir hatırlayalım.
Stood sort, stable sort, partial sort, partial sort copy, partition, stable partition, partition copy, is sorted, is sorted until partition point ve bir de heap algoritmaları.
Arkadaşlar şimdi onları belirli bir sırayla zaten görmeye başlamıştık.
Hemen oraya geri dönelim. Hangi algoritmaları gördük? Sort algoritması ve hatırlayalım arkadaşlar bu tür algoritmaların hemen hepsi iki tane overloada sahip.
Overloadlardan biri ben buna default overload diyorum. Genel olarak ya studless'i alıyor ya da bir binary predikatı default argüman olarak alıyor.
Diğerinde siz kendiniz belirtebiliyorsunuz. İşte stood sort böyleydi değil mi?
Stood sort aslında less'i kullanıyor. Yani küçük taraf operatörünü kullanıyor.
Ama karşılaştırma kriteri olarak diğer overloadu sizden bir binary predikat istiyor dedik.
Sortla stable sort arasındaki farkı gördük ki önemli.
Stable sort aynı değere sahip öğelerin sıralamadan önceki izafi konumlarını koruyor idi.
Fakat arkadaşlar sort böyle bir garanti vermiyor.
Ondan sonra dedik ki partial sort. Partial sort adı üstünde bizim bizde en yakın sözcük kısmi.
Kısmi sıralama. Arkadaşlar son derece basit.
Bir range'in bütün öğelerini değil de ilk en öğesini sıralayacaksınız.
Yine burada default overloadu stoodless'i alacak.
Yani küçüktür operatörüyle karşılaştırma yapacak.
Ve arkadaşlar diğer overload ise sizden yine binary predikat isteyecek.
Örneklerimizi genel olarak vektörden veriyoruz.
Ama ben her bir algoritma için algoritmanın talep ettiği iteratör kategorisini de birlikte sizinle burada görüyoruz.
Ben size gösteriyorum.
Evet, algoritm başlık dosyasını dahil edelim.
Bizim test kodları için utility başlık dosyamızı dahil edelim.
Bir de şimdilik using namespace direktifini kullanalım.
Vektörün string açılımı svec ve string başlık dosyasında include ettik.
süper random fill fonksiyonuyla svec arkadaşlar 10 bin tane efendim bir lambda ifadesi de burada kullanıyorum.
Daha önceki örneklere paralel olarak return random name.
random name.
Evet, artı bir boşluk random surname.
Evet, böylece arkadaşlar şurada da bir artı operatörü olacak.
Böylece 10 bin tane isim soy isim taşıyan yazıyla doldurduk sevgili vektörümüzü.
Şimdi bakalım partial sort arkadaşlar.
Yalnız burada parametrik yapı biraz farklı.
Partial sortun yine öncelikle random axis iteratör aldığını görüyorsunuz.
Ve birinci ve üçüncü parametre bu sefer range.
İkinci parametre arkadaşlar sıralanmış range'in end'i.
Yani şu demek, diyelim ki ilk 10 tanesini sıralamak istiyorsanız nasıl çare yapacaksınız?
svec begin, efendim next svec begin artı virgül 10 ya da doğrudan toplam order operatörüyle svec begin artı 10 ve arkadaşlar svec end.
Böylece ilk 10 öğe sıralanmış olacak.
Tabii ki yine küçüktür operatörüyle.
Arkadaşlar burada geriye kalan öğelerin sıralı olması konusunda tabii ki bir garanti yok.
Yine şöyle yapalım.
Bir dosyaya yazdıralım.
Alt nokta txt dosyasına.
cprint
svec
newline
ve operatörüyle.
Böylece daha iyi gösterme şansına sahip olacağım.
Derliyorum arkadaşlar.
ve çalıştırıyorum.
Evet hemen alt nokta txt dosyamıza bakıyoruz.
Arkadaşlar bakın leksikografik compare olduğu için
abdi acuka buraya kadar ilk 10 tane sıralı ama geriye kalanlar sıralı değil.
Şimdi biraz oynayalım algoritmamızda.
Ne yapalım?
Mesela bunu tabii dinamik olarak da alabilirdik değil mi?
Yani şöyle bir prompt verseydim arkadaşlar.
int n
ilk
cout
kaç
ve sıralansın
efendim
c'in
üç harikli bir
nesnemiz
c in n
ve buraya da
svec
begin
artı
n
ikinci parametreye
argüman olarak bu iteratör konumunu
geçse idim.
Tekrar
derliyi çalıştırıyorum.
İlk katöre sıralansın.
İlk
20v'e sıralansın.
Ve alt nokta txt'ye bakıyoruz.
O kez
ilk 20v'ye.
Peki
ikinci overloadu kullanalım.
Necati ikinci overloadu kullanmak için sıralama kriterini geçeceksin değil mi?
Evet
arkadaşlar
bu sefer sıralama kriteri için
önce
yine
geçen derste öğrendiklerimize
bir vurgu yapmak için
functional
başlık dosyasını dahil edelim ve
greater
function
objektini.
Standart creator'ı kullanalım.
Bu sefer de
büyükten küçüğe sıralama yapsın.
İlk kaç öğe sıralansın?
İlk
10 öğe
ama sıralama
büyükten küçüğe yapıldı.
Zübeyde Hanımlar
başta Zübeyde yürekli
Zübeyde yorgancı
Zübeyde yılgın
böyle gidiyor.
Tabii kendi
sıralama kriterimizde
olabilirdi.
Değil mi?
Peki
Arkadaşlar
şimdi
partial sort
copy'i
tahmin edebilirsiniz.
Zaten
içinde
copy geçen
copy sözcüğü
geçen
algoritmaların
genel yapısını
artık kavradık.
Tahmin edin
partial sort
copy ne yapacak?
N tane
öğeyi
sıralanmış
şekilde
bir range'e
yazacak.
yani range'in
kendisi
üstünde bir
değişiklik
yapmayacak.
Mesela
mesela
şuraya kadar
kodu
koruyalım.
İzleyin
arkadaşlar.
İlk
kaç öğe bu da
kalsın.
Fakat
şimdi
partial
sort
copy için
bir
hedef
range
verilip
mesela
vector'ün
yine
string açılımı
dest
back
parça
sort
copy
birinci
ve ikinci
parametre
arkadaşlar
input range
bu artık
random axis
teratör
olmak zorunda
değil.
Örneğin bu
listede
olabilirdi.
Listin
string açılımı
S list
ama şimdi
bakın
partial
sort
copy
birinci ve ikinci
parametre
input range
yani
S list
begin
end
üçüncü
parametre
arkadaşlar
dördüncü
parametre
izleyin
evet
üçüncü ve dördüncü
parametre
bunların
kopyalanacağı
aralık
ama bu
random axis
teratör istiyor.
Dolayısıyla
yine
vektörün
string açılımı
şunu da
sileyim bu arada
çünkü
bu bizden
öve sayısı
istemeyecek.
Vektörün
string açılımı
dest
vek
tamam.
Şimdi
üçüncü ve dördüncü
parametreye
ne geçeceğim?
Buradaki
aralığı
geçeceğim.
Örneğin
burada
on tane
öve olsun
ve biz de
bu range'e
en büyük
ya da en küçük
on taneyi
yazmış olalım.
O zaman nasıl
çağıracağım?
destvek
begin
biraz tuhaf
sırası
destvek
end
bu şekilde.
tekrar edelim mi
şöyle
bu range'teki
öveleri
sanki sıralanmış
gibi
bu range'e
kopyalacağım.
Bu range'in
bu range'de
kaç tane öve varsa
o kadar öve
kopyalanacak.
Evet şu anda
örneğin
ilk 10 öveyi
kopyalamış
oluyorum.
ve
tabii ki
arkadaşlar
destvek'i
yazdırırsam
print
c
destvek
buraya
sıralanmış
halde
ilk
bu range'de
10 tane öve olduğu için
10 öve
kopyalanmış
olacak.
Yine
diğer overloaduna
ne geçebilirim?
Arkadaşlar
şunu da
new line'i
kullanalım.
Evet
diğer overloaduna
kendi binary
predikatımı
geçebilirim.
Süper.
Evet
mesela
greater'ı
argüman olarak
verseydim
bu sefer de
en büyük
10 öveyi
kopyalamış
olacak.
Evet
arkadaşlar
Alihan
Bozkır
kaç tane
sıralanıp
kopyalanacağı
hedef range'in
uzunluğuyla
belirleniyor?
Evet
yani örneğin
burada
20 tane öve
olsaydı
aynı
range
argümanlarını
verseydim
3.
ve 4.
parametreye
ilk 20 öve
kopyalanmış
olacaktı
ya da son
örnekte.
O zaman
neyi de
gördük?
Partial sort
ve partial sort
kopya algoritmalarını
da gördük.
Şimdi
gelelim
partition
algoritmalarına.
birden fazla
partition
algoritması
var.
Partition
algoritması
Arkadaşlar
partition
normal
ben C
kursunda da
arkadaşlarla
implemente ediyorum.
S-list içinde
o kadar
eleman yoksa
undefined
behavior
mı?
Bir düşünelim
şimdi
S-list içinde
o kadar
eleman yoksa
undefined
behavior
mı?
good question
öyle diyorlar ya
soruya hemen
cevap veremediğiniz
zaman
good question
Arkadaşlar
bir bakmam
lazım.
Şimdi
yanlış bir şey
de söylemek
istemiyorum.
Un
hedef range'i
aldığına göre
algoritmayı
kafamda
canlandırmaya
çalışıyorum.
Sıralı
N tane
V'yi
yazacak.
Muhtemelen
undefined
behavior
olması lazım.
Ama yine
bakayım yani
peşin peşin
bir şey söylemek
istemiyorum.
Çünkü
açıkçası
ben de
şimdi
düşünüyorum
undefined
behavior
mı değil
mi?
Evet.
Bir bakarız
beraber oldu mu?
Hatta
isterseniz
beraber
şimdi
bakalım.
Uzatmayalım.
Güzel bir
soru çünkü.
Çaklıma gelmedi
böyle bir
soru.
Stood
partial
sort
copy
CPP
reference
Hemen
bakıyoruz.
Arkadaşlar
şimdi bizim
kullandığımız
algoritma
şu az önceki.
Yani
input iterator
first, input iterator
last bir
numara.
Elements are sorted
with respect to
operator
küçüktür.
Okey,
stood less.
Elements
sorted
vesaire.
If
yıldız first
is not
writable to
d first
the program
is
ill
formed.
ama
soru
bu değil.
Çünkü
burada ne
diyor?
Eğer diyor
yıldız first
d first
yazılamayacak
durumdaysa
ill
formed.
Ama
orange'deki
ö'ye kadar
ö'ye sahip
değilse
onu
yazmış
mı?
Yazmamış.
bakıyorum.
Evet,
güzel soru
dedik.
cppreference.com
da belirtmemiş.
Ben yanlış
anlamadım
değil mi?
Beraber düşünelim.
Soru şu.
Az önceki
örneğe geri
dönelim.
Diyor ki
arkadaşım
mesela
burada
20 tane
V var
ama
burada
10 tane
V
olsaydı
burada
10 tane
V
olsaydı
tanımsız
davranış
olur muydu?
Valla
tabii
sorunun cevabı
değil ama
bir
bir bak
edelim
en azından
yani
tanımsız
davranış
olmaya
da
bilir
doğrusu
isterseniz.
Şimdi
bu durumda
10 tane
ö'ye
yazacak.
Zaten
bir
bakalım
tamam
hemen
doğru cevabı
veriyorum.
Kesinlikle
tanımsız
davranış
değil.
Neden
tanımsız
davranış
değil?
Evet
çünkü
arkadaşlar
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
zaten
yine
en son
yazdığı
öğeden
sonraki
öğenin
konumu.
Yani
algoritmayı
şöyle
çalıştırsaydım
auto
iter
partial
sort
copy
ve
şimdi
efendim
geri dönüş
değerini
range'in
end'i
olarak
kullanarak
o range'i
yazdırsaydım
jprint
dest
back
begin
iter
new line
hiçbir problem
olmayacak.
Evet
kesin cevabı
veriyorum
Oğuzhan
tanımsız
davranış
değil.
Kesinlikle
Evet
peki
o zaman
biraz zorladı
soru
beni itiraf
edeyim.
Evet
arkadaşlar
peki
şimdi
geldik
yani
cpp
reference
konumda
olmamasının
nedeni de
orayı suçlamayalım
aslında
sorunun cevabı
çok açık.
Yani
neden böyle
bir mecburiyet
olsun?
Çünkü
zaten
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
en son
yazılan
konumdan
sonraki
konum.
O yüzden
tanımsız
davranış
olması
doğru
olmazdı.
Şimdi
gelelim
partition.
Önce
partition
ne demek?
Arkadaşlar
partition
bir range'i
bir koşulu
sağlayanlar
ve sağlamayanlar
olarak
ikiye ayırmak.
Range'in
başında
koşulu
sağlayanlar
olacak.
Range'in
sonunda
koşulu
sağlamayanlar
olacak.
Örneğin
şöyle bir
range'imiz
olsaydı
Biz
bu range'i
predikat'ımız
is
even
yani
ve çift
sayımı
is even
olacak şekilde
partition'a
tabi
tutsaydık
çiftler
başta
olacaktı.
Mesela
çift
buraya dikkat
arkadaşlar
çift
bir 4
daha var
o da çift
evet
bir de
2 var
yanılmıyorsam
başka kaldı mı
kalmadı.
İşte bakın
gerisi de
şöyle olsaydı
Arkadaşlar
buraya dikkat
şimdi
tıkkı
sortlu
olduğu gibi
partition
algoritması da
stable
olabilir ya da
olmayabilir.
Mesela ben
şu anda
eğer yanlış
yazmadıysam
yukarıdaki
range'i
çiftler
başta
çift
olmayanlar
sonunda
olmak üzere
partition'a
tabi
tuttum
ama bu
stable
partition
değil.
Eğer
stable
partition
olsaydı
izafi
konumlar
korunacaktı.
Yani
örneğin
2 daha
başta
arkadaşlar
özür dilerim
tam tersi
4 daha
başta
sonra
eğer
böyle
olsaydı
daha önceki
izafi
konumları
korunmuş olurdu
değil mi?
İşte
zaten
partition ile
stable
partition arasındaki
fark
sort ile
stable
sort arasındaki
farkın
aynısı.
Stable
olduğunda
partition
yapmadan
önceki
arkadaşlar
predikatı
sağlayanların
izafi
konumu
korunuyor.
yalnız
yalnız burada
önemli bir kavram
daha var
arkadaşlar
o da
partition
point
koşulu
sağlayanların
rencinin
endi
ister böyle
ifade edin
koşulu
sağlayan
sağlamayan
ilk
öğenin
konumu
çünkü
çoğunlukla
partition
yaparken
pointe de
ihtiyacınız
oluyor
çoğunlukla
her zaman
olmasa da
buradaki
algoritmalar
stup
partition
arkadaşlar
copy
stable
partition
copy
is
partition
ve
point
eksik kalmadı
umarım
partition
stable
copy
is
partition
ve partition
point
hemen
partition ve
stable
partition
ile başlıyoruz
arkadaşlar
bakın
basit bir
ilk
örneğimiz
çok basit
olsun
vektörün
int
açılımı
ivek
20 tane
ve
anılağında
j
print
partition
yeri dönüş
değeri
partition
point
o yüzden
onu da
bir değişkende
tutuyorum
işime
yaramayacaksa
tutmama
gerek yok
tahmin
edebildiğiniz
gibi
bir kere
forward
iteratör
istiyor
random
access
iteratör
olma
mecburiyeti
yok
ivek'in
beg'ini
end'i
üçüncü parametreye
de
predicate
olarak
oner
predicate
olarak
gerçekten
çift
olma
koşulunu
getireyim
ve
partition
gerçekleştikten
sonra
önce
partition
edilmiş
range'i
yazdırayım
sonra
partition
point'i
index
olarak
yazdırayım
partition
point
idx
eşittir
iter
eksi
ibek
beg'in
bir de
şöyle bir şey
yazdıralım
the first
lm
that
doesn't
satisfy
the
predicate
is
yıldız
iter
onu da
yazdırmış olalım
derliyorum
ve bakıyoruz
arkadaşlar
izleyiniz
bakınız
bizim
partisyon
noktamız
indeksimiz
sıfır
ve oradaki
öye
şimdi bir şeye
dikkat etmenizi
istiyorum
bir kere de
her şeyi
göstermiş olun
arkadaşlar
bakın
9'a
11'e
kadar
hepsi çift
11'in
bulunduğu yer
iteratör konumu
bizim
partition
point'imiz
yani
biz
beg'inle
partition
point'i bir
range
yapsaydık
koşulu sağlayanlar
orada olacaktı
Alihan
partition
point'la
end'i bir
range
yapsaydık
koşulu
sağlamayanlar
orada olacaktı
ama
bakalım bir şey
daha dikkatinizi
çekiyor mu
sıralı
bravo
Alihan
ben de onu
gösterecektim
arkadaşlar
partition
yapmadan önce
sıra şöyleydi
ama bakın
girmiş
araya
eğer
stable
partition
olsaydı
bu
izafi konum
korunacaktı
peki
şimdi
a
partition
yerini
stable partition'ı
çağıralım
hemen burada
bir kere
park'ı
görelim
arkadaşlar
izleyiniz
bakınız
5'e kadar
çiftler
ama görüyorsunuz
değil mi
gördüğünüz gibi
bu çekte
gidiyor
koşulu sağlamayanlara
bakalım
arkadaşlar
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
koşulu sağlamayanlarda
böyle bir garanti yok
zaten olsaydı
arkadaşlar
böyle bir garanti
dikkat çekiyor
var
şöyle bakalım
evet evet
var
onlarda da var
evet
ilk önce koşulu sağlayanlar
sonra sağlamayanlar
olmak zorunda mı
evet
ilk önce koşulu sağlayanlar
sonra sağlamayanlar
ama bunlar kendi içinde
herhangi bir şekilde
bir sıralama falan yok
sadece
arkadaşlar
izafi sıralak korunuyor
bir örnek daha yapalım
daha iyi görülmesi için
bu sefer
vektörün
string açılımı
aspect
50 tane
random name
bu örnek biraz daha güzel olacak
bakınız
c print
aspect
şimdi bakınız
charge
siyahat
içinde
hangi
harf
olanlar
c in
c
stable partition
aspect
begin
end
capture
c
aliham
bozkır
hocam
partition'da
kullanılan
sıralamanın
bir garantisi
var mı
onu söyledim
eğer
stable
partition
değilse
bir garanti
yok
ama
stable
partition ise
partisyondan
önceki izafi konumlar
korunmak zorunda
soruyu doğru
anladıysam
cevabı bu
c'yi
capture ediyorum
const
string
ref
s
return
contents
c
plus plus
23'ü
karıştırdık
ama
c
print
sv
şimdi içinde
bu harfi olanlar
alian
başta olacak
içinde o harfi
olmayanlar
sonda olacak
ama
stable olup olmamasını
talep etmek
sizin elinizde
partition'ı
kullanırsanız
böyle bir garanti
yok
evet
bakınız
arkadaşlar
içinde hangi
harfi olanlar
mesela
içinde
e harfi
olanlar
Nuriye
Berk
Mürüvvet
Emrecan
Cem
Nedim
Samet
Devrim
nereye kadar geliyor
arkadaşlar
şuradaki
Tarkan'a kadar geliyor
partition point'te
kim var
Tarkan var
anlaşıldı mı
bu
stable partition mı
değil
o yüzden örneğin
arkadaşlar
Emrecan'ın
Berk'in
Emrecan'dan
önce olma garantisi
yok aslında
Berk
Mürüvvet
Emrecan
o varsa
zaten bakın
burada bozuyor
Cem'den önce
devrimin
olması gerekirdi
Akser'de değil mi
oysa
stable partition
olsaydı
sayıda
biraz azaltalım
20 yapalım
stable partition
olsaydı
izafi konum
ayağın korunacaktı
şimdi bakın
içinde hangi harfi olanlar
E
gördünüz
şu sırayla olacak
değil mi
Efecan
Ege
Şemsit
böyle gidiyor
Efecan
Ege
İzzet
varmış
Efecan
Ege
İzzet
Şemsit
Ferah
Gülşen
bir daha
Ferah
Eda
Bekir
Bülent
Jade
bu sırayla
gidiyor
anlaşıldı mı
Emirhan
Şelik
reference
wrapper tutan
bir vektör
içinde
partition
yapabiliriz
değil mi
tabii ki
yapabilirsiniz
ama burada
sizin
unary
predikatınız
bu sefer
reference
wrapper
olacak
yani
konteynerda
tutulan
öğeyi
alması
gerekiyor
reference
wrapper
da bir sınıf
yani
reference
wrapper
için
bu algoritmayı
çalıştırmanız
öğeleri
reference
wrapper
olan bir
range
için
bu algoritmayı
çalıştırmanız
da
bir problem
yok
peki
devam
şimdi
geldik
partition
copy
arkadaşlar
bakın
partition
copy
C++'ın
daha önce
öğrendiğimiz
bazı
başka
özelliklerine
de
belki
gönderme
yapmamızı
sağlayacak
çünkü
partition
sort
copy
tahmin edin
bu sefer
kopyalıyor
range'in
kendisi
üstünde
bir partition
işlemi
yapmıyor
range'i
predikatı
sağlayanları
bir range'e
sağlamayanları
yazıyor
yani şöyle
bir algoritmadan
bahsediyoruz
bakınız
diyelim ki
bizim range'deki
öğelerimiz
arkadaşlar
şimdi
çiftleri
çift olup olmaması
bizim predikatımız olsa
şöyle yapacak
çiftleri bir yere yazacak
bir range yazacak
onun için bizden bir iteratör isteyecek
bir range
çiftleri yazacak
bir başka range'de
onun için de bir iteratör isteyecek
oraya da teklere yazacak
arkadaşlar
gibi
yaz burada ilginç bir özellik var
bence
çok da güzel gösteriyor
daha önce değindiğim bir konuyu
normalde
yazma algoritmaları
yani
bireyince
aktaran
yazan algoritmalar
en son yazdığı konumdan
sonraki konumu döndürüyorlar
ama
burada
2 range'e birden yazdığı için
2 tane konum döndürmesi gerekiyor
konvensyonel olarak
onun için
partition copy algoritmasının
geri dönüş değeri
iteratör pairi
anladık mı
tekrar edeyim mi
partition copy algoritmasının
geri dönüş değeri
iteratör pairi
hadi
arkadaşlar
şimdi biraz değiştirelim
ve
buraya kadar
kalsın
şimdi 2 tane daha
range oluşturuyorum
listin
string açılımı
arkadaşlar
ok list
burada 20 tane olsun
isme bakmayın
listin string açılımı
not ok list
şimdi
partition copy'yi çağırıyorum
partition copy
ve bakınız
arkadaşlar
algoritmamızın
birinci ve ikinci parametresi
kaynak range
in it
first in it last
üçüncü ve dördüncü parametreleri
sırasıyla
koşulu sağlayanların
yazılacağı range'in
başlangıcı
koşulu sağlamayanların
arkadaşlar
yazılacağı range'in
başlangıcı
ve fonksiyonun
geri dönüş değeri
son parametre yine
unary predicate
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş değeri
dikkat ederseniz
auditor 1
auditor 2
pairi
bu arada
bunların
ikisinde list olması da
gerekmez
hatta
onu da göstermek için
bir tanesini de deck yapalım
şimdi bakın
partition copy
geri dönüş değerini
auto
henüz size anlatmadığım
ama ilerleyen
dönemde saatlerde anlatacağım
structured binding ile
alayım
auto
arkadaşlar
evet şöyle diyelim
list and
deck and
pairi ayrıştırıyorum
aslında
bu
structured binding olmadan
bir kere gösterelim
sonra da
structured binding'in
ne kadar güzel bir
araç olduğuna da
örnek olsun
partition copy
evet
aspect begin
aspect and
koşulu sağlayanları
okey liste yazıyorum
okey liste
begin
sağlamayanları
not okey liste
yazıyorum
begin
unary predicate
olarak da
yine
capture
c
arkadaşlar
return
const
string
revs
return
s
contains
c
şimdi eğer
arkadaşlar
structured binding
olmasaydı
şöyle yazacaktım
fonksiyonun geri dönüş
diyeni
pairde tutacaktım
o da
arkadaşlar
p iter
yani
pair
iter
pair anlamında
eşittir
ve
bu durumda
p iter'in
first'ü
okey range'in
end konumu
olacaktı
hata yazdıralım
print
arkadaşlar
okey list
şunu da
deck yapalım
dedik ama
yapmamış
tamam yapalım
deck'in
string açılımı
not okey
deck
şurayı da
değiştireyim
not okey
deck
evet
c print
hatta şöyle diyelim
c out
türkçe yazacağım
koşulu sağlayanlar
c print
range parametreli bir
print fonksiyonumuz vardı
okey list
begin
ve
p iter'in
first'ü
arkadaşlar
diğeri de
okey deck
begin
hey
iter'in
second'ü
not okey
deck
begin
evet
derliyorum
çalıştırıyorum
evet
içinde hangi
tarif olanlar
iyi olanlar
koşulu sağlayanlar
Asım Hakkı
Devrim
Sinem
Fahri Cahit
Selim Mücahit
Cebrail
Dürriye
sağlamayanlar
Melek Selenay
vesaire
bari örneği
komple
tarih getirelim
sağlamayanlar
ve bir kez daha
çalıştıralım
içinde
E olanlar
koşulu sağlayanlar
Fikret
Necmeddin
Ayyip
Öncer
Nusret
koşulu sağlamayanlar
Nedim
Emrecan
Ece
Sinem
Ceyhun
Yaşar
Bekir
vesaire
arkadaşlar
bakın şimdi
range
structure
binding
C++
standardıyla
dile eklenen
önemli araçlardan
biri
ileride inşallah
ilerleyen
saatlerde
anlatacağım
arkadaşlar
ve
işimizi çok kolaylaştırıyor
böyle durumlarda
yani bir ayrıştırma
gerektiğinde
doğrudan şöyle
yazabiliyoruz
ama detayları
şimdi sormayın
bu
C++
isim veriyorum
örneğin
arkadaşlar
ok
and
not ok
bunlar
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri olan
pair'in
first'üne ve
second'ına
verdiğim
İngilizcesiyle
aliaslar
dolayısıyla
artık şöyle
yazabilirim
pair
hiç işin içinde
olmayacak
gizli
örtülü
kalacak
ok
and
ve
not ok
and
arkadaşlar
tabi burada
stable
çünkü
zaten
tek tek gidip
bir oraya
yazıyor
yani
koşulu sağlayanları
bir yere yazıyor
sağlamayanları
diğerine göre
çok daha kolay
iki farklı
range yerine
aynı range
kullanarak
partition copy'de
koşulu sağlayanların
hemen ardına
koşulu sağlamayanları
ekle
diyebilir miyiz
soruyu anlamadım
iki farkları
içerine
aynı range
kullanarak
partition copy'de
koşulu sağlayanların
hemen ardına
arkadaşlar
diyebilirsiniz ama
sayısını
baştan bilmeniz
gerekiyor
çünkü sizden
konum istiyor
yani şu
konumdan
başlayarak
ve bu
konumdan
başlayarak
yazacak
eğer
konteynerınızda
öğe varsa
bu konumlarda
sizin
bildiğiniz
konumlarsa
hesaplanmış
evet
structured binding
de oto olmak
zorunda mı
evet
structured binding
de oto olmak
zorunda
ama şimdi o bir
cümleyle anlatılabilecek
bir şey değil
arkadaşlar
normalde ileri
C++
koşusunda
çok ayrıntılı
anlatıyorum
ama
burada da
isterseniz
hangi gün
bugün
pazartesi
çarşamba günü
şöyle bir
45 dakika
1 saat
structured binding
anlatabilirim
ya da daha sonraki
başka bir dersi
şimdi
çok kısa
cevaplar
verirsem
ne sizin
sorularınıza
tatmin edici
bir cevap
vermiş olurum
ne de
beni tatmin eder
o yüzden
şöyle bir
en az
1 saat
ayırmamız
gerekiyor
o konuya
evet
sadece
tuppleda
değil
structured binding
arkadaşlar
şimdi
emiranda
beni konuya
anlatmaya
tahrik ediyor
isterseniz
çok kısa
bahsediğim
bir giriş
olsun
siz bilirsiniz
arkadaşlar
şimdi
zannettiğiniz kadar
kolay değil
biraz karmaşık
öncelikle
bir ön bilgi
vereyim o zaman
sonra
ayrıntılar
anlatayım
öncelikle
structured binding
şuradan başlayalım
bir
sentaxı var
o sentaxı
değiştiremiyoruz
sentax şöyle
auto key word'ünden
sonra
bu köşeli parantez
içinde
verdiğiniz isimler
burada
deklaratörler
olabilir
mesela
autoref
olabilir
ref olabilir
onstotoref
olabilir
ama
sadece
auto
olmak zorunda
burada
neyi
ayrıştırıyorsanız
ayrıştırdığınız
ve sayısı
kadar
isim
identifier
olmak zorunda
örneğin
ayrıştıracağınız
varlığın
üç tane
üyesi varsa
isim
olmak zorunda
iki tane
üyesi varsa
isim
olmak zorunda
ayrıştırılacak
varlık
örneğin
üç tane
üyeye
sahipse
fakat siz
burada
iki tane
isim
kullanırsanız
sentax hatası
örneğin
tuple'nızda
beş tane
üye varsa
ama siz
buraya
dört tane
isim
koyarsanız
sentax hatası
yani
sorunuzun kısa
cevabı
arkadaşlar
yalnız şöyle
bir özellik var
şimdi
izi türleri
için
ve
eskiden
POD
denilen
türler için
plain old data
yani basit
structure türleri
için
ben özetin
özetini
anlatıyorum
structured binding
core
sentaxi
olarak
destekleniyor
ama
bunların dışında
sınıf türleri
için
structured binding
kullanabilmeniz
için
couple
interface
dediğimiz
bir
interface
sağlaması
gerekiyor
bu
interface
de
üç tane
üye var
arkadaşlar
biri
tuple size
bunların hepsi
meta function
diğeri
tuple element
diğeri de
get
tuple size
ve tuple element
bunlar
meta fonksiyon
sınıf
şablonu
get ise
fonksiyon
şablonu
örneğin
stu
tuple
pair
ve
c++
3 ile
kompleks
tuple
interface'i
sağladığı için
orada kullanabiliriz
arkadaşlar
stu
array
dahil
kendi türlerim
içinde
structured
binding'i
kullanabilir miyim
cevap
evet
işte o
konuya
o konuyu
detaylı olarak
ele aldığımda
bunların hepsini
anlatıyorum
ben de
kendi türüm için
tuple
interface'i
size'ı
tuple
element'i
eğer
sağlarsam
benim
kendi türüm için
bir custom
type içinde
structured
binding
kullanabilirim
arkadaşlar
şuradan da
görebilirsiniz
eğer çok adil
bir ihtiyacınız
varsa ben
bu konuyu
anlatana
kadar
benim
gitapta
bakın
structured
bindings
burada
en azından
örnek
kodlar
var
25 tane
structure
binding ile ilgili
arkadaşlar
gördüğünüz gibi
kod var
normalde
ilerisi
plus plus
kursunda
ayrıntılı
anlatıyorum
ama
dilerseniz
bu kursda
da ayrıntılı
anlatabilirim
evet
biraz zaman
sorunumuz var
sadece
emiran
kısaca
böyle
evet
peki
şimdi
nerede
kaldık
partition
copy
görüyorduk
hemen oraya
bir geri dönelim
emiran
sorusuna
kısa
bir cevap
vermek
istedim
işte
burada
arkadaşlar
structured
binding'i
kullandım
fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri olan
iteratör
pairini
ayrıştırmak
için
arkadaşlar
işte
partition
copy
de böyle
efendim bir de
partition point'ı
görelim
ve
is partition
da görelim
son derece
basit
arkadaşlar
bir engin
partisyon
olup olmadığını
sınamak için
kullanılıyor
onu çok basit bir
örnek üstünde
gösterelim
mesela
vektörün
int açılımı
vek
arkadaşlar
mesela bu
ekler başta
çiftler
sonda
olmak üzere
partisyon halinde
bu range
o predikata
göre
tabii ki
o zaman
arkadaşlar
auto
b
eşittir
is
partitioned
wegbegin
doğrudan
input iteratörü
istiyor
zaten
wegbegin
wegend
int x
return
x mod 2
eşit değil
şimdi true
döndürmesi
gerekiyor
cout
bool alfa
b
gördüğünüz gibi
true
ama buraya
örneğin bir
shift sayı
ekleseydim
artlık range
partisyon durumunda
olmaktan
çıkacaktı
ve fonksiyonumuzda
bu durumda
false değer
döndürecekti
partisyon pointisi
abdül kadir akar
iteratör
invalidation
konuştunuz mu
hayır
henüz
anlatmadım
sadece şöyle
geçen derste
bir soru
sordum
mülakatlarda
sık sorulan
bir soru
dedim
sorunun tipik
olarak
cevaplanırken
cevapların
yanlış verildiğini
onun nedeninin de
programcıların
iteratör
invalidation
konusunu
tipik olarak
öğrenmemiş
oldukları
olmaları
olduğunu söyledim
onun cevabını
biraz daha
sonraya bıraktım
hem arkadaşlar
soruyu kendileri
çözmeye
çalışsınlar
ama
önümüzdeki derslerde
iteratör
invalidation
nedir
neden
önemlidir
onu göreceğiz
özellikle bakın
DEC
container'ı
söz konusu
olduğunda
genelde
iteratör
invalidation
ile DEC'in
ilişkisini
pek fazla
ne diyelim
telaffuz etmiyor
bu
kaynaklar
fakat
DEC'in
kullanılma
senaryolarından
biri de
DEC'le
vektörün
iteratör
invalidation
kuralları
ya da
koşulları
birbirinden
farklı
yani
bazı durumlarda
DEC
işlemlerin
belirli bir
biçimde yapılması
durumunda
iteratörlerin
demeyelim de
referansın
ya da
duruma göre
iteratörlerin
invalid
olmamasını
sağlıyor
bu arada
bir terime de
dikkat
arkadaşlar
bakınız
terim
iteratör
invalidation
terimde de
bir yanlışlık
var
iteratör
invalidation
peki
bu terim
sadece
iteratörlerle
mi ilgili
cevap
hayır
özellikle
DEC'le
bu önemli
iteratör
invalidation
şöyle
algılanıyor
sanki sadece
iteratörleri
ilgilendiriyor
oysa
standart açık
açık şunu
söylüyor
iteratör
invalidation
derken
A
gerçekten
iteratörler
söz konusu
olabilir
B
arkadaşlar
referans
grubu
onu da şöyle
diyelim
pointer
ve
referans
grubu
söz konusu
olabilir
mesela öyle
durumlar var ki
DEC'te
bu durum
var
doğrusu
isterseniz
iteratör
invalid
oluyor
ama
referans
invalid
olmuyor
ama
öyle
durumlar
var ki
iteratör
invalid
hale geliyor
ama
referans
da
invalid
hale
geliyor
o yüzden
o konuyu
beklememizde
fayda var
Akkadir
siz sordunuz
diye
cevap verdim
şimdi
yoksa
detaylı
anlatacağım
Efendim
partition
copy
stable
partition
copy
is
partition
bir de
point
partition
yapılmış
bir range
de
partition
noktasını
bulmaya
yarıyor
aman
dikkat
bunun için
range'in
zaten
partition
haline
gelmiş
olması
gerekiyor
mesela
ve
görün
arkadaşlar
efendim
int
açılımı
ya da
string
açılımı
esvek
ali
gül
eda
can
hakan
tabi
dersli
mi
tabi
mehmet
can
emir
han
arkadaşlar
bir şey
dikkatinizi çekiyor
mu
özellikle
üç harflileri
üç harf ederken
alt birindeki
karşılığından
bahsetmiyorum
üç harfe
sahip olanları
başa koydum
şimdi ben
unary
predikat olarak
string'in
uzunluğunun
üç olması
koşulunu
verirsem
aslında
bu range
partition
durumunda
çünkü
üç harfler
başta
arkadaşlar
üç harfi
olmayanlar
sonda
buraya kadar
tamam mı
evet
şimdi
partition
point'i
çağıralım
auto
hiper
eşit
stot
partition
point
arkadaşlar
iterator
svek
begin
end
predikat'ı
ona göre
vereceğim
const
string
rep
s
return
length
equal
three
see out
partition
point
ama bu arada
dikkat bakın
şimdi ben
bu range'de ne var
bilmeden
yılgız iter
deseydim
tanımsız
savranış
olabilir miydi
a
olabilirdi
b
olmazdı
range'deki
öğelerin
değerini
bilmiyorum
olabilirdi
neden
bravo
Mehmet Can
çünkü
bütün öğeler
de koşulu
sağlayabilir
bütün öğeler
koşulu
sağlarsa
partition
point
range'in
end'i
olacak
dolayısıyla
end konumunu
dereferens
etmiş
olacaksınız
if
iter
eşit
değilse
s
vek'in
end'i
index'i yazdırırsam
bir problem yok
öyle yazdırayım
isterseniz
t
out
idx
for
partition
point
eşittir
to distance
s
vek
begin
iter
s vek'in
değişik
değilse
c
out
yıldız
iter
hiç
üç artlı
yoksa
o soruya cevap
verdim
hiç
üç artlı
yoksa
arkadaşlar
o zaman
partition point
ilk öğenin
konumu
olacak
öyle değil mi
koşulu
sağlamayanların
ilki
dolayısıyla
örneğin
onu da
isterseniz
göstereyim
anlaşıldı
değil mi
o yüzden
onu özellikle
belirtmedim
önce böyle bir
başlatalım
bakın
idx
for partition
point
dört
eğer range'imiz
sadece
koşulu
sağlayanlardan
oluşsaydı
arkadaşlar
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
yanlış yazmışız
şöyle yapalım
sadece
koşulu
sağlayanlardan
oluşsaydı
şimdi oldu
sanırım
şurada
noktalı
bir
gördük
kaldı
şimdi oldu
evet
o zaman
el konumunu
döndürecekti
dolayısıyla
index dört
olacaktı
evet
hiçbiri
koşulu sağlamıyor
olsaydı
o zaman
koşulu
sağlamayanların
ilk olduğu için
arkadaşlar
index sıfır
olacaktı
oradaki
öğe de
halkan
olacaktı
aliyans
sorunuzun cevabı
sanıyorum bu
partition point'i de
gördük
arkadaşlar
şimdi
gelelim
son
alt başlığımıza
tabi
algoritmalarla
ilgili son
alt başlığımız
değil de
günün
algoritmalarla
ilgili son
alt başlığını
heap
algoritmaları
arkadaşlar
şimdi konunun
tam olarak
anlaşılması için
hepimizin
heap
data
structures
hakkında
bilgi sahibi
olması gerekiyor
heap
veri yapısı
buradaki
heap
o bellek
segmenti olan
heap değil
ama o bellek
segmenti olan
heap'in ismi de
buradan geliyor
zaten
heap bir
veri yapısı
arkadaşlar
heap aslında
binary
tree'lerin
özel bir
biçimi
yani özel bir
ikili ağaç
öyle bir
ikili ağaç ki
isterseniz şurada
şekil üstünde
gösterelim
önce heap'in ne olduğu
konusunda
mutlaka
arkadaşlarımın
hemen hepsi
biliyordur ama
küçük bir
bilgi verelim
heap
şöyle bir
arkadaşlar
binary
tree
eğer
min heap ise
buraya dikkat
arkadaşlar
her bir düğümdeki
öğe
ağaçtaki
çocuklarından
daha küçük
eğer heap böyle
düzenlenmişse
buna min heap
deniyor
eğer tersi ise
arkadaşlar
yani
her bir
düğümdeki
öğe
çocuklarından
daha büyükse
buna da
max heap
deniyor
önce
heap'in ne olduğunu
bir anlayalım
arkadaşlar
heap olma özelliğini
sağlaması için
ağacın
dengeli
olması gerekiyor
yani
bunun
iki tane
çocuğu var
çocukları
bundan küçük
mesela bu çocuk
arkadaşlar
diyelim ki
değerinde
bu çocuk
pek
koçul bu
bir de
dengelenmiş
olması
gerekiyor
mesela bunların da
çocukları
olsun
bunların
564'ün
çocukları
564'ten
küçük eşit
olacak
örneğin
712'nin
çocukları da
712'den
küçük olacak
mesela şöyle
olabilir mi
efendim
ya da
raza
vikosun
şu anda halen
heap koşulu
sağlanıyor
şöyle oklada
gösterelim mi
bunun çocukları
bunlar
yani eğer herkes
heap veri yapısını
biliyorsa
hiç bunları
anlatmayayım
doğrudan
konuya geçin
arkadaşlar
mesela burada
bir çocuk
olabilir mi
olabilir
tamamen
seviyenin
olması
gerekmiyor
mesela
burada
çocuklar
şimdi
heap veri yapısının
özelliği ne
arkadaşlar
doğrudan
bir ağaç olarak
yani tipik
ikili arama ağacında
olduğu gibi
düğüm
düğümün içinde
iki tane
pointer
pointerlar
çocukları gösteriyor
sol çocuk
sağ çocuk
bu şekilde
implement edilebildiği
gibi
dengeli olması
nedeniyle
vektörel bir
veri yapısını
heap olarak
kullanabiliyoruz
arkadaşlar
şimdi bunun
açılmış şekline
bakın
lütfen
şöyle olsaydı
bunları bir
vektörde
tutsaydım
yani bir
dizide
tutsaydım
şöyle olacaktı
ondan sonraki
indekslerde
bunun çocukları
efendim
arkadaşlar
şimdi
564'ün
çocukları
efendim
şimdi
ve
yani bunu
bir ağaç
şeklinde
implemente etmekle
vektörel
veri yapısında
öğeleri
bu
ağaçtaki
sıralarıyla
vektörel
bir veri yapısında
tutmak arasında
bir fark yok
bu durumda
712'nin
çocukları
564'den
büyük
712'den
küçük
olabilir mi
olabilir
hiçbir engel
yok
burada bütün
hikaye şu
bunu
vektörel
hale getirdiğim
zaman
aslında
çocukları
arkadaşlar
şu formülle
indeksini
bulabiliyorum
mesela bunun
indeksi
sıfır
bunun çocuklarının
indeksi
arkadaşlar
2i
artı 1
artı 2
o zaman
sıfır
indeksindekilerin
çocukları ne
ve 2
indeksindekiler
örneğin
2 indeksindekilerin
çocukları kim
2i
artı 1
arkadaşlar
öyle değil mi
2i
artı 2
dolayısıyla
3 4 5 6
bakın
gerçekten de
712'nin
çocukları
bunlar
değil mi
buraya kadar
anlaşıldı mı
evet
şimdi arkadaşlar
bu hip veri yapısının
önemli özelliği
az önce söylediğim gibi
her düğümdeki
öğenin
kendi çocuklarından
büyük olması
eğer
max hipse
o çok büyük bir
fark değil değil mi
o sizin
belirlediğiniz
düzene göre
değişiyor
eğer
min hip
oluşturacaksanız
bu sefer de
tam tersi
her düğümdeki
öğe
kendi
ağacındaki
en küçük
öğe olacak
şimdi
hipin
kullanıldığı
ana senaryo
priority
queue dediğimiz
veri yapısı
yani bir
hipi
priority queue
türkçeye ben
öncelik kuyruğu
diye çeviriyorum
veri yapısı
olarak
kullanabiliyorsunuz
kaldı ki
STL'de zaten
bir container
adaptörü olarak
İngilizce
container
adaptör
deniyor
bir
öncelik kuyruğu
veri yapısı
implementasyonu
var
öncelik kuyruğu
ne demek
kuyruğun ne
olduğunu biliyorsunuz
queue
arkadaşlar
ilk giren
ilk çıkar
öncelik kuyruğunda
ise
kuyrukta
öğeler var
ama
önceliği
en yüksek
olan
kuyruktan
çıkıyor
mesela
öncelik
şimdi
değerlerin
büyüklüğü ise
bunları bu şekilde
bir hip olarak
tutuyorsam
kuyruktan
ilk çıkacak
öğe hangisi
cevap
peki
876'nın
arkadaşlar
çıkması için
kuyruktan
ne yapmam
gerekiyor
çok basit bir
algoritmayı
koşturmam
gerekiyor ki
işte buradaki
algoritmalar
hep o
logan karmaşılığındaki
algoritmalar
aslında bu
benim
konteynerimdaki
son öğe değil mi
öyle değil mi
evet
o zaman bakın
kuyruktaki ilk
öğeye çıkartacağım
değerini
elde edebilirim
ama son derece
basit
bunu
aslında
buradaki
son
elemanla
takas edeceğim
yani
buraya gelecek
e şimdi
876'ya artık
çıkartabilirim
224'ü de
arkadaşlar
yerine koymak
için
aşağı doğru
çocuklarından
büyük olanı ile
takas edeceğim
buraya gelecek
efendim
böylece
heap olma özelliği
bozulmamış olacak
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
arkadaşlar
ekleme de
benzer şekilde
yine
o
logan karmaşıklığında
mesela
buraya
bu sefer de
diyelim ki
698'i
ekleseydim
pushback yapacağım
evet
şimdi
698'i
ne yapmam
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
yerini
almam
gerekiyor
bu sefer de
yukarı doğru
kaydırarak
yerini alacağım
efendim
234'le
rakas ettim
ve
564'le
rakas ettim
takip edebiliyor muyuz
işte
yine
heap olma özelliği
bozulmadı
şimdi
dolayısıyla
öncelik kuyruğu
demek
heap demek
heap'in de
kullanıldığı
tek yer
öncelik kuyruğu
olmasa da
hep öncelik kuyruğu ile
priority queue ile
birlikte anılır
ama dikkat şimdi
heap'in bir özelliği
daha var
arkadaşlar
bir veri yapısını
heap haline
getirmek
vektörel bir veri
yapısını
heap haline
getirmeye
İngilizce'de
heapify
deniyor
yani ben
birazdan göstereceğim
algoritmaları
bir veri yapısını
heapify
algoritmasıyla
heap haline
getirebilirim
buraya kadar anlaşıldı mı
ama heap haline
getirilmiş
bir veri yapısının
sıralanması da
arkadaşlar
yine
belirli bir
algoritmik karmaşıklıkta
hepsini göstereceğim
işte
heap sort
algoritması da
bu zaten
yani heap sort
algoritması
birazdan onu da
göreceğiz
önce
bir range'i
heap haline
getiriyor
arkadaşlar
ondan sonra da
heap haline
getirilmiş range'i
ne yapıyor
sıralıyor
sıralı hale
getiriyor
bu da
endlogen karmaşıklığında
bir algoritma
şimdi
gelelim
buradaki
bizim
STL'deki
algoritmalarımıza
başlangıçta
biraz karmaşık
gelebilir
arkadaşlar
bir kere
vektörel bir
veri yapısı
olması gerekiyor
o açık
çünkü
bellekte
ardışık
olacak ki
kontügyüs
az önceki
özellikten
yani
bu ağacı
vektörel bir veri
yapısı haline
ifade edebilelim
buradaki
algoritmalara
gelince
arkadaşlar
algoritmaların
isimleri şöyle
make heap
o da üstünde
birinci heap
haline getiriyor
efendim
pop heap
push heap
heap'e
insert etmek
için
arkadaşlar
çağıracağımız
algoritma
yani
konteyner'a
sondan ekleme
yapıp
ondan sonra
push heap
fonksiyonunu
çağırdığınız zaman
log and
karmaşıklığında
onu
yerine koyuyor
tersi de
pop heap
yani pop heap
fonksiyonunu
çağırdığınız zaman
aslında ne yapıyor
o
heap'teki
en büyük değeri
max
hepsi
range'in
sonuna
alıyor
böylece
ben ona
a erişik
değerini
öğrenebiliyorum
ve
oradaki
konteynerin
pop back
fonksiyonunu
çağırarak
yani son öğe
silerek
heap'ten
çıkartabiliyorum
o zaman
fonksiyonlarımız
şunlar
make heap
hepsini göreceğiz
arkadaşlar
push heap
top heap
ve
sort heap
işte
sort heap de
bizim bildiğimiz
heap sort
algoritması
yani
arkadaşlar
o yüzden
mesela heap sort
diye bir
algoritma da yok
bu da mülakatlardaki
çok klasik
sorulardan biri
mesela heap sort
algoritmasıyla
sıralama yapmanız
istenebilir
bir
jenerik
fonksiyon olarak
ne yapacaksınız
önce range'i
heap durumuna
getireceksiniz
sonra da
sort heap
fonksiyonunu
çağıracaksınız
bunu tek bir
fonksiyonla
sarmalarsanız
alın size
heap sort
algoritması
şimdi bir görelim
arkadaşlar
bakın şimdi
baştan sona
dikkatli takip etmeye
çalışıyorum
vektörün
int açılımı
ivek
efendim
random fill
ivek
ne olsun
şöyle
kolay takip
edebilmeniz için
25 tane
değer olsun
ayrent
sıfır
arkadaşlar
bin
ve şimdi
print
jprint
arkadaşlar
ivek
hatta
şöyle yapalım
biraz daha güzel
yazmak istiyorum
şöyle yapalım
bir dosya açalım
ekrandan
kopyalama
derdimiz
olmasın
jprint
ivek
borçluk
arkadaşlar
ofs
şimdi ilk olarak
make heap
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
make heap
buraya dikkat
arkadaşlar görüyorsunuz
geri dönüş değeri yok
ve random access
teratörü istiyor
dolayısıyla
ivek
begin
dediğimi
ivek
end
şimdi
buradaki
default
karşılaştırma
kriteri
less
olduğu için
doğrudan
max heap
oluşuyor
şu anda
max heap
ama ben
örneğin
önceliği
kendim
belirlemek
için
fonksiyonun
diğer
overloaduna
örneğin
greater
argüman
olarak gönderebilirdim
ya da
kendi
karşılaştırma
kriterimi
argüman
olarak
gönderebilirdim
şimdi
cprint'i
tekrar
çağırıyorum
ve size
gösteriyorum
başlangıçta
biraz
karmaşık gibi
ama heap
çok kolay
bir veri yapısı
arkadaşlar
bakın şimdi
bu heap
olmadan
önceki
haliydi
bu da
heap
olduktan
sonra
şimdi
bunun
max heap
olduğunu
görebiliyoruz
değil mi
arkadaşlar
971'in
çocukları
bunlar
964'ün
çocukları
arkadaşlar
bunlar
hadi gelin
bunu gösterelim
bakın
çocukları
arkadaşlar
öyle gidiyor
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
yayman
gerek
bunun için de
ben program
yazmıştım
onu bulursam
evet
şu hale getiriyor
print ederken
böyle gidiyor
gördünüz
değil mi
heap olduğunu
şimdi
bak
eğer bu
max heap yerine
min heap yapmak
isteseydim
arkadaşlar
tabii ki
şimdi max heap yaparsam
burada
öncelik
buyruğu olarak
kullanırsam
kim çıkacak
ilk önce
önceliğe en yüksek
olan
yani burada
önceliğin en yüksek
olduğunu belirten
aslında bizim
karşılaştırma
kriterimiz
şimdi min heap
haline getirelim
o zaman
fonksiyonun
üçüncü parametresine
ne geçeceğim
greater
function
objectini
geçeceğim
greater
şimdi min heap
oldu
bakın
arkadaşlar
sıfır
önceliğin
yüksek olan
ama bu kez
en küçük olan
ve
onun çocukları
arkadaşlar
102 39
ondan büyük
bunun çocukları
bundan büyük
253'ün çocukları
253'den büyük
173'ün çocukları
173'den büyük
ya da eşit
anlaşıldı mı?
şimdi yipinli olduğunu
anladık mı?
tamam
gelelim diğer
heap operasyonlarına
make heap son derece
basit
görüyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
daha sonra
bu
cppreference.com'dan
algoritmik karmaşıklığını
da gösterebilirim
hocam
heap kullanılan
bir gerçek hayat
durumuna örnek
verebilir misiniz?
arkadaşlar
yüzlerce örnek
verebilirim
en çok kullanılan
veri yapılarından
bir tanesiyiz
öncelik kuyruğu
mesela
üntiyinim ki
bir hizmet
alacaklar var
bir koddan
hizmet alacak
kutlar var
siz önceliklerine göre
hizmeti veriyorsunuz
hizmeti
en yüksek
öncelikliye
ilk hizmeti
veriyorsunuz
ondan daha
düşük öncelikliye
ikinci
hizmeti
veriyorsunuz
en tipik
en tipik senaryo
zaten bu
arkadaşlar
mesela
efendim
prosesleri
threadleri
vesaire
bu yolda
bir öncelik
kuyruğuna
koyabilirsiniz
tabii ki
threadpool'da da
kullanılıyor
olabilir
yani
bildiğiniz herhangi bir
senaryoda
kullanabilirsiniz
ama şimdi önce
bir algoritmaları
görelim
ondan sonra
zaten bir öncelik
kuyruğu
oluşturacağız
arkadaşlar
mesela
en basit örnek
fighterların
savaşma güçleri
var
siz fighterları
bir öncelik
kuyruğunda
tutuyorsunuz
oyunun
senaryosu
gereği
önce
en güçsüz
savaşçıyı
çıkartacaksınız
sonra ondan
bir güçlüsüne
ondan bir güçlüsüne
bunlar savaşacak
diyelim ki
diğer düşmanın
savaşçılarıyla
o zaman
bunları
önceliğine göre
oradan çıkartmanız
gerekiyor
ya da mesela
diyor ki
Abdülkadir
çok güzel bir örnek
verdi
hastane sırası
diyor
hastaların
bir şekilde
ölçülebilir
aciliyet durumları
olacak
hastanede de
teker teker
hastalar
alınıyor
en acil olan
ilk olarak
alınacak
adam kalp krizi
geçiriyor
önce onun
alınması gerekiyor
ondan sonra
ne bileyim
işte beyin
kanaması
geçiriyor
o alınmıyor
Abdülkadir'in
örneğini
kullanıyorum
peki
şimdi gelelim
arkadaşlar
hop hip'e
bakın bakın
şimdi çok dikkatli izleyin
push hip'e
özür dilerim
hip'e
ö ekleyeceğiz
değil mi
hip'e ö eklemek için
ne yapıyoruz
herkes dikkatli izliyor
biz
range'e ö'yi
pushback fonksiyonu ile
ekliyoruz
mesela kaçı
ekleyelim
arkadaşlar
efendim
475'e
ekleyelim
ya da 675'e
konteynera
ibek
pushback
ö'yi ekledim
şimdi pop hip'i
çağırıyorum
pop hip
push hip
push hip'i çağırıyorum
hatta bakın
her kademede
yazdıracağım
tekrar
şunu biraz sayısını
daha azaltayım
mesela
14 olsun
push hip
şimdi vektörü
tekrar yazdırıyorum
arkadaşlar
ve
push hip fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
push hip
if
şimdi tekrar
ip haline geldi
isterseniz bakın
bu örnek çok öğretiş aslında
dosya üstünde
yazıyor olmamız
kolaylıkla güzel gösteriyor
evet bakın şimdi
şu range hip değildi
hip haline getirdim
bu arada
greater
peki greater olsun
hip haline getirdim
şu anda hip olmuş durumda
sonra 772'yi buraya koydum
hip olma özelliği bozuldu
ama sonra
arkadaşlar
tekrar
ki ama
bir dakika
bir greater
burada greater'ı çağırmamışım
o yüzden şöyle yapayım
anladınız değil mi
push hipte de greater'ı
vermem gerekiyordu
ve biz normal yine
max hipten devam edelim
evet
bakınız şimdi
şu anda max hip oldu
772'yi buraya ekledim
hop
push hip fonksiyonunu çağırınca
772 gelmesi gereken yere geldi
push hipin ne olduğunu anladınız mı
yani aslında push hip demek
öncelik kuyruğuna
yeni bir eleman eklemek demek
bu da
log en karmaşıklığında
gelelim pop hip'e
pop hip de
mesela şu anda
arkadaşlar bu sefer
bunu sileyim
diyelim ki
en yüksek öncelikli
hayır
bu işlemlerin hepsi hipte mi
hip ile hiçbir alakası yok
hip veri yapısının ismi
onu kaçırmış olabilirsiniz
emiram
benmek segmenti olan
hip ile alakası yok
bütün bu işlemler
bu vektör üstünde yapılıyor
yani işlemler bu vektörde yapılıyor
vektör öğeleri
hipte tutuyor
o ayrı
yani
bellek segmenti olan
hip ile
hani stack
hip
burayı karıştırmayın
demiştim
hip burada veri yapısının ismi
arkadaşlar
bakın pop hip
şimdi çok dikkatli izleyin
pop hipte ne yapacağım
elemanı
en sona alacağım
en yüksek öncelikli olanı
onun için pop hip'i çağırıyorum
pop hip
ibek begin
ibek end
peki
şimdi söyleyin bakalım
önceliği en yüksek olan
şimdi nerede
vektörün sonunda
yani ben şimdi
vektörün back fonksiyonunu
çağırırsam
arkadaşlar
en yüksek öncelikli
vektörün back fonksiyonunu
çağırırsam
o elemanı
erişmiş olacağım
vek
ibek'in
beki
yani son elemanı
beki hatırlıyorsunuz
değil mi
peki şimdi
onu hipten çıkartmam
gerekecek
onun için de
arkadaşlar
doğrudan
ibek'in
pop back fonksiyonunu
çağıracağım
şimdi arkadaşım
örnek istemişti ya
size mükemmel
bir örnek vereceğim
anlamadığınız
hiçbir şey kalmayacak
öncelik buyruğuyla
ilgili
bakın en yüksek
öncelikli
arkadaşlar
görüyorsun
bakın şimdi
çok basit bir örnek
yapalım
bizim bir string
vektörümüz var
vektörün
string açılımı
svek
ve bu string vektöründe
isimler var
isim soy isim
svek
20 tane
ne daha önce
kullandığım kod
return
random name
arkadaşlar
artı
bir boşluk
random
surname
takip edin sadece
şimdi bu
benim için bir
öncelik buyruğu olsun
istiyorum
ama öncelik
az önce örnek verdik ya
mesela
thread'in önceliği
prosesin önceliği
hastanın önceliği
fighter'ın
gücüne göre
önceliği
bizim de burada
önceliğimiz
arkadaşlar
isimlerin
uzunluğu olsun
yani
en uzun isim
en önce
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
isimlerin uzunluğu
ya da belki
isimlerin
alfabetik sırası olsun
tamam
isimlerin alfabetik
sırası olsun
dolayısıyla
ben kuyruktan
her bir
öğeyi
çıkardığımda
Emirhan
çıkardığım
öğe ne olacak
kuyruktaki
tutulan
isimlerden
en büyüğü
olacak
ama bu
sıralı değil
bakın sıralı
olmadığına
dikkat edin
arkadaşlar
ve
diyelim ki
çıkarttığım öğe
Zeynep
Aksoy
sonra
tekrar
bu sefer
kalanların
en
önceliklisini
çıkarsam
bu seferde
ikinci
büyük isim
örneğin
Yeşim
Egemen
çıkacak
gibi
şimdi bunu
yapmak için
bakın
bütün fonksiyonları
bir arada
kullanacağız
önce bunu
mecbur ne haline
getiriyorum
heap haline
make heap
arkadaşlar
bakınız
make heap'in
algoritmik
karmaşıklığı
sıralamayla
heap haline
getirmeyi
karıştırmayalım
arkadaşlar
izleyin
make heap'in
karşılığı ne
algoritmik
kompleksdesi
ON
yani bir
vektörel veri
yapısını
heap haline
getirmek
ON
karmaşıklığında
dolayısıyla
siz
ON
karmaşıklığında
heap haline
getiriyorsunuz
ve
buradan
diyelim ki
en yüksek
öncelikliği
almanızda
o da
o
log
karmaşıklığında
burayı anladık mı
evet
peki
make heap
sveg
begin
her şey anlaşılacak
sveg begin
sveg
end
süper
heap haline
geldi mi
geldi
şimdi
vektör
boşalana
kadar
döngüsel
her bir yapıda
her bir
öğeyi
önceliğine göre
tek tek alacağım
yani en yüksek
öncelikliği
önce alacağım
yalnız bir şeye
dikkat edin
şu anda bu
ne heap
arkadaşlar
max heap
max heap olduğu için
en büyük
öğe gelecek
değil mi
zaten de
istediğim bu
örneğe böyle
vermiştim
şimdi izleyin
arkadaşlar
while
efendim
sveg
empty olmadığı
sürece
sırası ile yaptığım
işlemlere bakın
önce
pop heap
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
pop heap
sveg
begin
end
böylece
vektör de
sona gitti
şimdi en yüksek
öncelikliği
yazdırıyorum
cout
arkadaşlar
sveg
back
böylece
yazdırdım
void
get car
şimdi onu
container'dan
çıkarttım
arkadaşlar
sveg
pop heap
işte bu kadar
alın size
en basit bir
öncelik kuyruğu
uygulaması
tabi ki
str'deki
priority queue
jenerik sınıfı
bunun için bize
bir interfej veriyor
şimdi ben bir
interfej olmadan
sadece
öncelik kuyruğu
haline getirdim
ve döngünler durumda
öncelik kuyruğundan
büyüğü çıkarttım
bakın
Zarife Derin
Yusuf Renacan
Yasemin Silipkeli
Yasemin Eli Ağar
Cicen Yıkılmaz
Tamer
Sezai
Sevilay
Nedim
Naz
Jülide
Gülden
Eylül
Cezme
Celal
Bekir
Azize
Ayla
Aydan
Adem
gördünüz değil mi
arkadaşlar
buraya kadar
anlamayan var mı
önce
öncelik
kuyruğu haline getirdim
OAN karmaşıklığında
bir algoritmayla
sonra tek tek
o Logan karmaşıklığında
algoritmayla
döngünler durumda
önceliği
en yüksek olanı
seçtim
burada öncelik
bunların büyüklüğü
önceliği
tabii ki siz
kendi
kriterinize göre
belirleyebilirsiniz
ben şimdi
burada
L'si kullandığım için
öncelik kriteri
en büyük değer
en yüksek
öncelikli oldu
anlamayanlar mı
size'ları değil
alfabetik sırayı
kullandım Oğuzhan
kaçırdınız
size'larına göre
sıralamadım
alfabetik sıra
çünkü string'in
L'si
leksikografical
compare yapıyor
anlaşıldı mı
alfabetik
leksikografical
anlaşıldı değil mi
eğer sizin
dediğiniz gibi
yapsaydım
bakın o zaman
şöyle olacak
hemen bir örnek
yapalım
daha önceki kriterimi
alıyorum
otope
şimdisini
dediğiniz gibi yapayım
constotope
eşittir
kendi kriterimi
kendim vereceğim
şimdi
fs2
return
s1 büyük
s2
ya da
özellikle s1
length
büyük s2 length
ya da
bunların length'leri
eşit
ama aynı zamanda
s1 büyük
s2
şimdi bu binary
predikat'ı
kullansaydım
ama her yerde
kullanacağım
make heap
f
pop heap
bu kadar
şimdi bakın
şimdi sizin dediğiniz
kalitere göre
gelecek
şunu kapatayım
evet bakın
sade bekar
ata uğursuz
azistan gün
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
en kısası
eğer ters yapmak
isteseydim
bu sefer
küçük
s1 küçük
s2
şimdi kriter bu
hatta şöyle
get card'ı
istemesin artık
tam sizin dediğiniz
şekilde
önceliği
değiştirdim
şu anda
anlaşıldı
değil mi
istediğiniz öncelik
kriterini
istediğiniz gibi
verebilirsiniz
anlaşıldı mı
bir de
tips orada
bakalım
diyelim ki
elimizde bir
vektör var
bu vektörü
heap sort
algoritmasıyla
sıralayacağız
sıralamamız
isteniyor
vektörün
int açılımı
ivek
bin tane
ve
iron
and
sıfır
yüz bin
önce
heap haline getiriyorum
make heap
ve ondan sonra da
arkadaşlar
ivek
peki
ivek and
evet
random
niye altını çizdi
ivek begin
ivek and
make heap
bazen bu
sapıtıyor
ya da ben bir şey
yanlış yazmış olabilirim
evet
yok
bir problem yok
tamam
ve
sort heap
ivek begin
ivek
and
arkadaşlar
mesela bunu
önce bir gösterelim
ve yazdıralım
jbrint
ivek begin
ya da
ivek
bu küçükten büyüğe sıraladı
bunu bir
algoritma haline de getirebilirdim
bakın
template
pipe name
arkadaşlar
run it
random access
denetörü
diyorum
algoritma
geri dönüş
değeri yok
heap
sort
run it
begin
and
bu ls'i kullanacak
run it begin
run it
and
işte
şunu buraya taşıyım
make heap
begin
and
bag olsunlar
ismi
run it
make heap
bag and
sort heap
diğerini de şöyle yazardım
bakın
keep sort
ikinci bir template parametresi var
pipe read
f
type name
pipe read
üçünlük parametresi var
f
make heap
bag and
f
işte bu da
diğer
overloadu
olacaktı
peki
bir ara verelim
saat
21.05
diyelim
21.25
de devam edeceğiz
arkadaşlar
sort heap'i ne güzel
implement etmiş
bakın
cppreference.com'daki
implementasyona
bakın
sort heap
random access
teratörü istiyor
first last
ve
kodun güzelliğine
bakar mısınız
first last
eşit olmadığı
sürece
pop heap'i
çağırıyor
şimdi pop heap
en yüksek
öncelikliyi
en sona atıyor
ya
arkadaşlar
o zaman
bu
range'in
en yüksek
önceliklisi
range'in
sonuna gidecek
ama ondan
sonraki turda
last'ı
bir eksiltiyor
bu
pre
post fixing
dekrement
operatörü
olduğu için
biliyorsunuz
ürettiği değer
kendi değeri
dolayısıyla
döngünün
her turunda
range'i
bir öğe
küçültüyor
bu sefer de
o range'in
en yüksek
önceliklisini
en sona koyuyor
böylece
first last
eşit olduğunda
range'de
sıralanmış oluyor
heap sort
algoritması
en log'in
karmaşıklığında
arkadaşlar
algoritmanın
karmaşıklığı
computational
context
içinde
bakın çok
güzel bir örneğin
genel kural
şudur
değil mi
bir algoritmanın
kompleksitesi
computational
en yüksek olan
basamağın
step'in
kompleksitesidir
şimdi heap sort
önce heap haline
getiriyor
o
on
ama ondan sonra
heap haline
getirilmiş
range'i
sort etmek
o da
en log'in
dolayısıyla
yine en log'in
karmaşıklığında
oluyor
yani
sort heap'in
kendi
karmaşıklığı
en log'in
arkadaşlar
zaten en log'in
olduğunu da
buradan görüyorsunuz
bakın bu
on
karmaşıklığında
bu da
log'in
karmaşıklığında
dolayısıyla
döngünler turunda
log'in karmaşıklığında
bir işlem yapıldığı
için
o en log'in
oluyor
aslında
o en log'in
karmaşıklığına
böyle çok tipik bir
örnek olarak
bu verilebilir
yani
konuyu anlat
algoritmanın
karmaşıklığı
konusunu anlatırken de
güzel bir örnek
olacağı açık
en log'in
çünkü örnek vermek
çok kolay olmuyor
daha karmaşık
algoritmalar
söz konusu
evet
peki
bir fonksiyonumuz
daha kaldı
bu en kolayı
is heap
yani
bir engin
heap olup
olmadığını
sınıyor
mesela şöyle bir
vektörümüz
olsaydı
vektör
efendim
vek
şimdi
12'nin
biraz daha büyütelim
120'nin
çocukları
buraya gelecek
efendim
ve
şimdi
112'nin
çocukları
buraya gelecek
değil mi
o da
ve
106'nın
çocukları
buraya gelecek
ve
bakın
heap gibi görünmese de
şu anda
heap data
structure
hemen bakalım
c6
full
alfa
arkadaşlar
is heap
tabi max heap
kontrolü yapmam gerekiyor
vek begin
ve
vek end
evet
eğer bir yanlışlık yapmadıysak
true olması gerekiyor
çünkü bu bir max heap şu anda
evet
ama heap olma özelliğini
bozalım
mesela
120'nin çocuklarından
112'nin çocuklarından biri
112'den büyük olsun
şimdi heap olma özelliği
bozuldu
evet
peki
algoritmalara daha sonra
geri döneceğiz
grup grup algoritmaları anlatıyorum
araya başka konuları alıyorum
arkadaşlar
bir başka grup olarak
şimdi değil ama
biraz daha sonra
sorted range algoritm istediğimiz bir grup var
bu algoritmalar
sıralanmış range'ler üstünde
işlem yapan algoritmalar
yani bu algoritmalardan
herhangi birini
koşturmak için
söz konusu range'in
daha önceden bir sıralama kriteriyle
sıralanmış olması gerekiyor
o yüzden bu algoritma grubuna
sorted range algoritms deniyor
ama
pek yakında
arkadaşlar
şimdi
ikinci konteynerımıza
geçebiliriz
şöyle biraz geriye saralım
dedik ki
birinci grup konteynerlarımız
sequence konteyner
sevgili vektör
deck
list
forward list
link
ve
stud array
ve c dizileri
bunlar
arkadaşlar
sequence
konteyner
ama tabi c dizilerinde
ekleme silme işlemleri
yok
şimdi vektörle
string'i gördük
aslında ikisi de
dinamik dizi
veri yapısı
fakat farkı
string
yazı işlemleri için
özelleştirilmiş bir
interfeste sahip
arkadaşlar
şimdi bunu
her ne kadar
çoğunluk
deck diye
telaffuz ediyor olsa da
decku diyen de vardı
eskiden
şimdi artık
decku
telaffuzu
yanlış kabul ediliyor
oysa
sözcüğün
aslında çıkışı
bence etimolojisi
double
ended
q
şimdi bu da önemli
bir veri yapısı
önce bu veri yapısının
amacı ne
ona bakalım
amacı
şunu sağlamak
dinamik dizide
sadece sondan ekleme
constant time'da
amortize
arkadaşlar
ve
indeks
değer işim
constant time'da
double
added q
da deck'e ise
hem
baştan
ekleme
hem
baştan
hem de
sondan
ekleme
amortize
constant time'da
ve
indeks
değer işim de
constant time'da
yani öyle bir
veri yapısı
düşünün ki
baştan da
ekleme
sondan da
constant time'da
fakat
indeks
değer işim de
constant time'da
aslında
burada
bunu sağlayan
bir başka
veri yapısı
daha olabilir
ona
boost
implemente ediyor
ona
devek diyor
arkadaşlar
circular q
eş ismi
mi?
hayır
circular q
eş ismi
değil
arkadaşlar
buradaki
hikaye şu
bakın nasıl böyle bir şey yapıyor
aslında arka planda
dinamik dizilerin
dizisi var
yani şöyle bir
veri yapısı olduğunu düşünün
şuraya
arkadaşlar şöyle bir
yine
şekil çizmeye
çalışalım
aslında
veriler
chunk
dediğimiz
birimlerde
chunk'lar
bir
vektörel veri yapısı
yani dinamik olarak
allocate ediliyor
mesela tipik olarak
implementasyonlarda
benim gördüğüm
chunk'larda
8 tane üve
tutuluyor
8 tane
üve'lik yer var
şunlar
şunlar bizim
chunk'larımız olsun
arkadaşlar
chunk'lardan birini
baştan ekleme
diğerini
sondan ekleme
için kullanıyor
mesela şu anda
iki tane chunk olduğunu
düşünelim
baştan ekleme
söz konusu olduğunda
diyelim ki
ekleme
buraya yapılacak
sondan ekleme
için de
başka chunk'ı
kullanacak
ve bu
chunk'lar
dolduğu zaman
yeni chunk'lar
oluşturulacak
yani aslında
dizilerin
dizisi
ve bunların da
adreslerini tutmak için
tipik bir
pointer
dizisine
ihtiyacınız var
şimdi
bu durumda
sondan ekleme
ve baştan
ekleme için
ayrı chunk'lar
kullanıldığı için
yine
constant time'da
amortize
ama
indekse erişim
aslında
basit bir
aritmetik
hesaplamayla
önce
pointer dizisinin
bir elemanına
erişiyorsunuz
şu da bizim
pointer dizimiz olsun
pointer dizisi
neyi tutuyor
bu
chunk'ların
adreslerini
tutuyor
dolayısıyla
siz örneğin
idx
indeksindeki
öyeye
erişirken
arka planda
şöyle bir
hesaplama yapılıyor
o hangi
chunk'ta
pointer dizisinin
bir elemanına
erişiliyor
o elemandan
ilgili
chunk'a
erişiliyor
o chunk'tan da
bir
indeksteki
öyeye
erişiliyor
yani
contiguous
değil
ama
indeksle
erişim
iki kez
dereferencingle
sağlanıyor
yani
chunk'ların
adresini
tutan
pointer dizisinin
ilgili elemanına
eriş
oradan
chunk'ın
adresine
eriş
oradan da
öyeye
erişmek için
o chunk'taki
bir
indeksteki
öyeye
eriş
şimdi
eğer
baştan
ekleme
ve sondan
arkadaşlar
çok sık
yapılıyorsa
sadece
sondan
ekleme
değil
aynı zamanda
baştan
ekleme
ama
indekste
de erişim
gerekiyorsa
DEC
sizin için
iyi bir
çözüm
olabilir
arkadaşlar
bir de DEC'in
başka bir
avantajı
ne
veriler
contiguous
şekilde
tutulmuyor
yani örneğin
bu
dinamik
dizi
olsaydı
800 tane
öyeyi
tutmak için
800 çarpı
size of
t'ye kadar
bellek alanının
allocate
edilmesi
gerekiyordu
ama
burada
ne yapılacak
arkadaşlar
chunk sayısı
kadar
diyelim ki
80 tane
kaç oluyor
100 tane
chunk varsa
chunk sayısı
kadar
ayrı bellek
alanı
allocate
ediliyor
ve bunların
adreslerinde
tutacak
bir
pointer
dizisi
olması
lazım
daha
fazlası
için
veri yapıları
ve
algoritmalar
kaynaklarına
bakabilirsiniz
bizi şimdi
ilgilendiren
baştan
eklemenin
sondan
constant
time'da
olması
ve
indekslerde
indeksle
erişimin
yine
constant
time'da
olması
tabi ki
alignment falan
bizim sorunumuz
değil
onu veri yapısı
kendisi
hallediyor
yani o
alignment ile
ilgilisinin
hiçbir probleminiz
yok
sonuna karışmıyorsunuz
siz sadece
interfeisteki fonksiyonları
çağırıyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
evet
tabi ki her veri yapısının
avantajları var
dezavantajları var
mesela buradaki
veri yapısının da
belki
önemli
dezavantajı
siz
deck'te
bir tane
öğe
tutsanız dahi
arkadaşlar
o chunk
ya da chunklar
en az
bir chunk
duruma göre
iki chunk
allocate edilmek
sorumda
bu da
bir deck'in
bir başka
belki
dezavantajı
arkadaşlar
şimdi
hemen
şöyle bir
deck örneği
verelim
önce template olarak
vektörle aynı
iki tane template
parametresi var
birinci template
parametresi
tıpkı vektörde
olduğu gibi
deck'te tutulacak
öğenin türü
ikinci template
parametresi
dinamik
benlik yönetimini
yapan
tür
o da
default argüman
olarak
stut allocator'ın
birinci template
parametresine karşılık
gelen
specialization'ı
alıyor
yani şöyle bir
templetten bahsediyoruz
yine
template type name
t
ve
type name
a
eşittir
stut
allocator'ın
t
açılımı
class
deck
böyle bir
template'ten
bahsediyoruz
arkadaşlar
burada
baştan ekleme
ve son
denekleme
constant time'de
olduğu için
baştan ekleme
ve baştan
silme işlemleri
içinde
yine
isimlendirilmiş
fonksiyonlar var
yani
vektörde olmayan
push
front
ve vektörde
olmayan
top front
fonksiyonları
da var
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
dolayısıyla push
front
pop front
ama yine
push back
pop back
fonksiyonları
da var
bunun dışında
fonksiyonların
arkadaşlar
yine
aynı olduğunu
söyleyebiliriz
o yüzden
çok fazla
zamanımızı
almayacak
bir şey
deck'in
kullanılması
için
birkaç tane
senaryo var
senaryolardan
bir tanesi
işte
baştan
eklemenin
sondan
eklemeyle
birlikte
sık yapılması
ikincisi
belki
iteratör
invalidation
kurallarının
farklı
olması
nedeniyle
bazı özel
durumlarda
vektör yerine
deck
kullanılması
üçüncü
bir kullanım
fikri
şu
olabilir
arkadaşlar
vektörün
boğul
açılımı
tutan
bir
vektör
değil
bu bir
partial
specialization
dolayısıyla
vektörün
boğul
açılımından
kaçınmak
için ki
bu konuya
değineceğim
deck'in
boğul
açılımını
kullanmada
yaygın
bir
durum
yani
vektörün
boğul
açılımının
fiilen
boğul
tutmamasından
etkilenenler
boğul
tutacak
gerçekten
boğul
tutacak
içsel
seviyede
tutulmayacak
gerçekten
boğul
tutacak
konteyner arayışında
olanlar
yine
deck'i
kullanmayı
tercih
edebiliyorlar
mesela
bakınız
basit örnek
verelim
deck'in
int
açılımı
constructor
grubu
aynı
insert
fonksiyonları
aynı
erase
fonksiyonları
aynı
yani
neredeyse
birebir
eş
interfejse
sahip
köşeli
parantez
operatör
fonksiyonu
yine
overload
edilmiş
efendim
at
isimli
operatör
fonksiyonu
yine
overload
edilmiş
yine
köşeli
parantez
operatör
fonksiyonu
index'in
geçersiz
olması
durumunda
exception
throw
etmiyor
ama
at
fonksiyonu
exception
throw
ediyor
mesela
deck'in
int
açılımı
türünden
dq
arkadaşlar
40 tane
ö ekleyelim
ama
çiftleri
başa
ekleyelim
sonları
pekleri
sona
ekleyelim
bir tane
rastgerası
yüretmek için
bir nesne
oluşturuyorum
irant
myrant
kapalı
aralığında
auto
while
eşittir
myrant
if
while
çift
ise
dq
push
front
arkadaşlar
while
aksi halde
dq
push
back
var
iteratörleri
random
access
iteratör
dolayısıyla
iteratörler
random
access
iteratör
olduğu
için
random
access
iteratör
isteyen
örneğin
sort
gibi
stable
sort
gibi
arkadaşlar
partial
sort
gibi
algoritmalara
argüman
olarak
gönderebilirim
şimdi
dq
dolaşayım
ister
yine
range
base
world
ile dolaşabilirim
auto
iyi
arkadaşlar
dq
see
out
iyi
buraya
kadar
derleyelim
evet
bakın
eklemeler
çiftler
başa
eklendi
tekrar
sona
eklendi
dolayısıyla
doğal
bir şekilde
artisyon
durumunda
tabi
şöyle de
dolaşabilirdim
viktor ile ilgili
söylediğim her şey
burada da
geçerli
for
size
d
idx
küçük
dq
nın
size
artı
arkadaşlar
tabi ki
bu
range
base
for
loop
dolaşma
en azından
geçersiz
index
kullanımına
karşı
iyi bir önlem
dolayısıyla
range
base
for
loop
ihtiyacımızı
gördüğü
noktada
mümkün
olduğu kadar
range
base
for
loop
kullanmakta
fayda
var
diğerinde
arkadaşlar
range
taşırma
dışına
çıkma
gibi
kodlama
adaları
daha
sık
karşımıza
çıkıyor
biraz
bu arada
bir şey
söyleyeyim
c++20
standardıyla
range
base
for
loop
adı
şöyle
bir ekleme
yapıldı
artık
birinci
kısımda
değişken
tanımlayabiliyorsunuz
yani örneğin
bu
daki
dolaşırken
diyelim ki
ayrı bir değişkene ihtiyacım var
inç
jnp
eşit
sıfır
arkadaşlar
efendim
auto
i
tq
c++20'den önce
bu mümkün
değildi
c++20
standardıyla
range
base
for
loop'un
genel
syntaxına
da
böyle bir
ekleme
yapıldı
bazı kodlar
da
gerçekten
işimizi
çok
kolaylaştırıyor
arkadaşlar
dk ile ilgili
önemli konu
konulardan bir tanesi de
az önce söylediğim gibi
dk'in
iteratör
invalidation
kuralları
vektörün
iteratör
invalidation
kurallarına göre
farklı
şimdi
önce bu
iteratör
invalidation
ne demek
oraya bir
dönelim
iteratör
invalidation
arkadaşlar
adı üstünde
invalidation
invalidate'in
isim hali
valid
geçerli
kılmak
invalid
geçersiz
kılmak
invalidation
geçersiz
kılınması
iteratörün
geçersiz
duruma
gelmesi
öyle durumlar
var ki
arkadaşlar
sizin elinizde
bir veri
yapısında
örneğin bir
konteynerda
tutulan
öğe'ye
a
iteratör
var
b
referans
var
bakın bu da
iteratör
invalidation'ın
konusu
referans
derken
burada
terim olarak
kullanıyorum
yani
lvalue
ya da
rvalue
referans
anlamında
değil
pointer
da olabilir
referans
yani
pointer
olması ile
referans
olması
arasında
burada
bir
fark
yok
arkadaşlar
bir işlem
yapıyorsunuz
ve o işlemin
sonucunda
daha önce
o veri
yapısındaki
bir
öğenin
en konumunu
tutan
bir
iteratör
ya da
o öğe'ye
bir pointer
ya da
o öğe'ye
bir referans
artık
geçerli
hale geliyor
hale gelmesi
şu olabilir
yani artık
ya o konumda
bir öğe yok
o konum
geçerli
bir konum
değil
yani o konumu
bir referans
edersen
tanımsız
davranış
olacak
ya da
o konum
halen
geçerli
ama o konumda
olması gereken
lojik olarak
öğe yok
dolayısıyla
bu şu
demek
arkadaşlar
invalid
hale gelen
bir iteratörü
kullanmamalısınız
de referans
etmemelisiniz
yani bir iteratör
invalid
hale geldiğinde
olabilecek
en iyi
senaryo
o iteratör
konumunu
de referans
edip
tanımsız
davranış
olmaması
ama orada
sizin
beklediğiniz
değerin
bulunmaması
ama tipik olarak
aynı zamanda
bunun
tanımsız
davranış
undefined
bir yer
olması
arkadaşlar
bazı senaryoları
çok kolay
tahmin edebilirsiniz
bakın mesela
iteratör
invalidation
en tipik örnek
vektördeki
sadece tek örnek
değil
vektördeki
reallocation
düşünsenize
sizin bir
vektörünüz
var
bakın
vektörün
int açılımı
ivek
ve
burada
bir
öğe'ye
iteratörünüz var
auto
iter
eşittir
diyelim ki
ibek
begin
şimdi
bu iteratör konumundaki
öğe'ye
erişmenizde
herhangi bir engel
yok
ama bakın
gerçekten
iteratörün
invalid olduğunu
size göstermek
kesin
gösterebilmek
için
vektörümüzün
bu durumda
kapasitesine
bakalım
ivek
kapasite
arkadaşlar
imiş
şimdi o zaman
kapasite
olduğuna göre
ben bir
ö
eklediğimde
örneğin
pushback
fonksiyonu
ve
değerini
sondan
ekleyeyim
artık
vektördeki
öyler
başka yere
taşındı
değil mi
size kapasiteye
eşitken
bir
insertion
olduğu için
reallocation
oldu
şimdi ben bu
iteratör konumundaki
öyeye
erişirsem
tanımsız
davranış
olacak
yani
iter
invalid
hale gelen
bir iteratör
oldu
şimdi
dikkatli izleyiniz
bakın
ben doğrudan
cppreference.com'dan
size
vektör ve
dek için
iteratör
invalidation
kurallarını
göstereceğim
beraber okuyacağız
ve yorumlayacağız
çünkü burası
çok çok önemli
bakın şimdi
standart
iteratörlerin
invalid hale
gelmesi
durumunu
açıkça
ekleme ve silme
işlemleri
olarak
ayrı ayrı
anlatıyor
şimdilik de
okuyalım
diyorum ki
değerli arkadaşlar
insert
and place
back
pushback
the functions
insert and place
back
and place
pushback
cause
reallocation
if the new size
is greater
than the old
capacity
yani
yeni kapasite
eski kapasiteden
yeni size
büyükse
bu fonksiyonları
çağırdığınız zaman
reallocation
olacak
invalidates
all the
references
pointers
and
iterators
referring to
the elements
in the
sequence
son derece
basit
yani reallocation
olduğunda
ister
pointer
olsun
ister
referans
olsun
ister
iteratör
olsun
arkadaşlar
reallocation'dan
önceki
durumdaki
iteratörler
yani alınmış
pointerler
referanslar
hepsi
invalid
hale gelecek
ama şimdi
bakın
if no
reallocation
happens
eğer bir
reallocation
olmazsa
yani
ekleme işlemi
yapıldı
ama
kapasite yeterli
reallocation
olmadı
all the
iterators
and
references
before the
insertion
point
remain
valid
yani
eklemenin
yapıldığı
konumdan
önceki
konumlara
olan
iteratörler
ve referanslar
geçerliliğini
koruyorlar
ama
eklemenin
yapıldığı
konumdan
önceki
konumlar
sonraki
invalid
oluyorlar
burayı
anladık mı
evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi
demek ki
bu arada
reserve
fonksiyonu da
aynı şekilde
bakın oraya
dokuyalım
reserve
kapasiteyi
rezerve
ediyordu ya
with respect to the reserve function
reallocation
invalidates
all the
references
pointers
and iterators
referring to the elements
in the sequence
yani
reallocation'a neden olursa
tabi ki
reserve fonksiyonu da
yine
arkadaşlar
iteratör
invalidation'a neden oluyor
ama bakın
deck'te kurul
durum farklı
şimdi
deck'e bakalım
deck gerçekten
çok ilginç
an insertion
in the middle
of the deck
invalidates
all the
iterators
and references
to the elements
of the deck
yani eklemeyi
ortadan yaparsanız
daha önce konuşmuştuk
in the middle
demek tam ortası
anlamında değil
yani baş ya da
son olmayan bir noktadan
insertion
yaparsanız
bütün
iteratörler
ve referanslar
yani pointerler
ne oluyor
invalid
hale geliyor
ama bakın
an insertion
at either
end of the deck
eğer ekleme
iki uçtan
birinden yapılıyorsa
yani baştan
ya da sondan
yapılıyorsa
örneğin
push front
ya da push back
fonksiyonlarıyla
yapılıyorsa
arkadaşlar
invalidates
all the
iterators
to the deck
but has
no effect
on the
validity
of
references
to elements
of the deck
yani ekleme
diyor
iki uçtan
birinden
yapıldığı zaman
iteratörler
invalid hale gelir
ama diyor
referanslar
yani pointerler
ve referanslar
invalid hale
gelmez
burayı anladık mı
yani deckte
durum farklı
deckte
eğer siz
eklemeyi sürekli
baştan
sonundan
yapıyorsanız
eklenmiş
daha önce
oyları
referans
tutuyorsanız
o referanslar
geçerliliğini
kaybetmiyor
ama iteratörler
geçerliliğini
kaybediyor
o yüzden dedim
terimin
iteratör
invalidation
olduğuna
bakmayın
sadece
iteratörlerle
ilgili değil
genelde de
ne sanılıyor
sanki
iteratör
invalidation
deyince
sadece
iteratörlere
ilgilendiren
bir terim
sanılıyor
devam ediyoruz
şimdi
silme işlemleri
arkadaşlar
bakın bu da
önemli
diyor ki
the functions
vektörde
arrays and
pop back
yani arrays
ve pop back
fonksiyonları
invalidate
iteratör
and
references
at
or
after
the point
of the
arrays
yani sen diyor
arrays ve pop back
fonksiyonlarından birini
çağırırsan
arkadaşlar
sildiğin öğeye
iteratör ve
referanslar
ve
ondan sonraki
öğelere
referanslar
invalid hale
geliyor ve
pointerlar
ama ondan
öncekiler
bundan etkilenmiyor
bu da önemli
bir garanti
yani örneğin
vektördeki
bakın mesela
bunu göstermenin
basit birkaç yolu
çok
arkadaşlar
vektörde de göstereceğim
vekte de göstereceğim
neden kritik olduğuna
bakın
mesela bir vektör
olalım
vektörün
yine int açılımı
ivek
o da iter
eşittir
ivek
and
eksi
yani bu konumda
şu anda 3 var
see out
yıldız
iter
şu ana kadar
bir iteratör
invalidation yok
ama şimdi
bakın
ivek
arrays
begin
artı
ben şunu
sildim değil mi
8'i sildim
8'i silmem
demek
8'i
tutan
o konumu tutan
bir iteratör varsa
onu invalid
etti
geçersiz kıldı
ama bundan
sonrakileri de
geçersiz kıldı
dolayısıyla
biz
bizim şu andaki
iterimiz
geçersiz
dolayısıyla
onu
dereferans ettiğimde
arkadaşlar
invalid
hale gelmiş
bir iteratörü
dereferans etmiş
oluyorum
gördüğünüz gibi
bu örnekte
3 yerine
7 var
ama tabi böyle bir
garanti olduğunu da
söyleyemeyiz
yani invalid
olan
iteratörü
asla kullanmamanız
gerekiyor
ama bakın
şimdi
dekteki örneğe
bakın
şimdi
dek bunu
çok güzel
gösterecek
bakın
dek
dq
şimdi
bir tane
ne yapayım
arkadaşlar
a iteratör
olayım
auto iter
eşittir
dq'nun
begin'i
artı
bu iteratör
begin'i artı 3
yani orada
7 değeri var
şimdi bu iteratörü
bir referans
edeyim
see out
yıldız iter
buraya kadar bir problem yok
ama aynı zamanda
ona bir de arkadaşlar
pointer olayım
izleyin
int
yıldız ptr
eşittir
adres
yıldız
iter
takip edebiliyor muyuz
see out
yıldız ptr
aynı değer olması
gerekir değil mi
ama şimdi
baştan ya da
sondan ekleme
yapıyorum
dq
pushback
pushpront
see out
yıldız iter
yıldız ptr
arkadaşlar
soru
yıldız iter'in
geçerli olduğunu
söyleyebilir miyiz
hayır
ama yıldız ptr'in
geçerli olduğunu
söyleyebilir miyiz
cevap evet
arkadaşlar bunu
anlamanın en güzel yolu
genelde
dibat modunda
çalıştırmak
bakınız
bakın şimdi
debugger devreye
girdi
ama
yıldız iter'i
koddan
çıkartayım
bakın debugger
devreye
girmedi
gördünüz
değil mi
neden
çünkü
pointer
arkadaşlar
invalid
hale
gelmedi
şimdi devam
az önceki
açıklamadan
deck'de de
silme
konumunda
silmede
iterator
invalidation
kuralları
farklı
bakın
an erase
operation
that erases
the last
element
of a deck
invalidates
only the
past
end
iterator
yani
eğer diyor ki
sen
son öğeyi
siliyorsan
bu durumda
sadece
end
konumu
doğal olarak
invalid
hale geliyor
onun dışında
hiçbir
arkadaşlar
iterator
ya da
referans
invalid
hale
gelmiyor
hadi ona da
örnek verelim
mesela
şu anda
bizim
yine
iter'imiz
şuraya kadar
olsun
bakın
ve
son öğeyi
sileyim
dq
popback
peki
iterator
ya da
pointer'ım
invalid
hale geldi mi
sondan öğe
sildiğim için
cevap
hayır
şimdi bakın
an
erase
operation
that
erases
the
first
element
of a deck
but
not
the
last
element
invalidates
only
iterators
and
references
to
the
erase
elements
yani
baştan
elemanı
sildiğinde
eğer bu
aynı zamanda
son eleman
değilse
yani
deck
dek
tek
ve
yoksa
arkadaşlar
sadece
end
konumunu
ve silinen
üyeye
konumu
invalid
hale getiriyor
yani bu da pratikte
ne demek
baştan ya da
sondan silme
yaptığınız zaman
demek
o zaman
sadece
silinen öğeler
silinen öğelere
iteratorler ve
referanslar
invalid hale
geliyor
diğerlerine
ortadan
ekleme
yapıldığında
bütün
iteratorler
ve pointer'lar
alian
invalidate
oluyor
alian
bey sormuş
ortadan
ekleme
yapıldığında
ne değişiyordu
ortadan
ekleme
yapıldığında
hepsi invalid
hale geliyor
yani
eğer kod şöyle
olsaydı
önce
alian sizin
sorunuza cevap
vereyim
kod şöyle
olsaydı
mesela
elimde bir
insert
fonksiyonunu
çağırayım
insert
dq
begin
artı
bir
bu iterator ve pointer
invalid oldu mu
kesinlikle
ortadan
yapılan
eklemelerde
bütün
iteratorlar
bakın hemen
debugger
devreye
girdi
emran
beyin
sorusu
reference
wrapper
tutan
konteynerler
için özel
bir durum
mevcut mu
hayır
şimdi
reference
wrapper
konusunu
yakında
anlatacağım
emran
orada
ayrıntılı
cevap
veririm
ama
bakın
bir
konteynerin
reference
wrapper
tutması
özel
bir durum
değil
reference
wrapper
bir
sınıf
yani
konteynerin
efendim
my class
sınıfı
türünden
nesneler
tutmasıyla
reference
wrapper
türünden
nesneler
tutması
arasında
hiçbir
fark
yok
ama
reference
wrapper
öyle bir
nesne ki
adı üstünde
bir referansa
sarmalıyor
aslında bir
pointer'ı
sarmalıyor
yani
reference
wrapper
arkadaşlar
İngilizcesiyle
Rebindable
Reference
Soyutlamasına
bir
implementasyon
başka bir şey
değil
isterseniz onu
reference wrapper
sınıfına
anlattığım
derste artık
çok da uzun
bir süre sonra
değil en fazla
2-3 hafta
bilemediniz
4 hafta içinde
göreceğimiz
konulardan biri
peki
burada gördük
değil mi
o zaman
alianın sorusuna
geri dönelim
alian
ekleme ya da
silme işlemleri
arkadaşlar
ortadan
yapılıyorsa
bütün
neler
bakın
tekrar buraya
gelelim
ekleme işlemi
ortadan
yapılıyorsa
bütün
referanslar
iteratörler
dek de
invalid hale
geliyor
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
efendim
silme işlemi
baştan
yapılıyorsa
silinen
növeye
olan
iteratör ve
referanslar
invalid hale
geliyor
diğer iteratörler
ve referanslar
etkilenmiyor
son eleman
silindiğinde
sadece
yine
silinen
üyeye
iteratör ve
referanslar
ve arkadaşlar
son
end konumu
invalid hale
geliyor
evet
en son
buraya gelmiştik
an erase operation
that erases
neither the first element
nor the last element
of a deck
eğer silinen
üye
ilk üye
değilse
son üye
yani ortadan
herhangi bir üyeyi
silerseniz
yine
invalid is
the past
the end
iterator
and all
iterators
and references
to all
elements
of the deck
işte demin
söylediğim
ortadan
ekleme de
yapsanız
silme de
bütün
iteratörler
ve referanslar
invalid hale
geliyor
dolayısıyla
gördüğümüz gibi
vektörün
iteratör
invalidation
kuralları ile
deck'in
iteratör
invalidation
kuralları
birbirinden
farklı
peki
arkadaşlar
şimdi
deck'i de
geçelim
ve hemen
bir sonraki
konteynerımıza
bakalım
interfej
neredeyse
tamamen aynı
onun üstünde
tek tek
durmayacağım
ha şu
bizim
meşhur
mülakat sorumuza
bakalım
arkadaşlar
şöyle bir soruydu
soruyu birebir
hatırlamıyorum
ama sonuçta
hepsi
aynı
öze sahip
dedim ki
string vektörü
var
vektörün
string açılımı
svec
random field
rn
random name
yok
uzunluğu 5 olanlardan
bir tane
eklenecek
uzunluğu 6 olanlar
silinecek
ya da tam tersi
c
print
fark etmiyor
şimdi yeni soru
sormuş
bunu
diyelim ki
uzunluğu
5 olanlar
silinecek
6 olanlardan
bir tane daha
eklenecek
diğerlerine dokunulmayacak
arkadaşlar
şimdi
şöyle bir kod yazıyorlar
ki
kod tabi ki
anında
göreceksiniz
iteratory invalidation
neden oluyor
auto iter
eşittir
svec begin
iter
eşittir
svec
and
artı
iter
işte
diyor ki
if
iter
of
land
yani bu iter konumundaki
öğrenilen
land
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
eşit
teşit
5 ise
konteynerimizin ismi de
svec
erase
yıldız iter
iter
özür dilerim
ersif
bu tabi ki yanlış kod
iter
ok
length
eşit
6 ise
svec
insert
iter
yıldız
tabi ki bu kod yanlış
arkadaşlar bir kere
reallocation
invalidate
ettik
insert ettiğimde
insert ettiğim konumdan
sonraki der
iter
invalid hale geldi
oraya iteratörler
silinmiş oraya iteratör
dahil
değil mi
ama yine de
tanımsız
davranış
oluşturan bu
senaryoyu
şeye print
yansırmaya
çalışalım
esvec
debugger devreye
girdi
ama
release modunda
derleyip
çalıştıralım
bunda da
gördüğünüz gibi
runtime hatası
oldu
peki ne yapmak
gerekiyordu
arkadaşlar son derece
basit
aslında
daha önce de
insert fonksiyonların
ve
ers fonksiyonlarını
anlatırken
konteynerların
bunların
geri dönüş
değerlerinin
son derece
önemli olduğunu
söylemiştim
şimdi
şöyle olduğunu
düşünelim
can
emrah
deniz
necati
aytaç
feride
nur
mert
şöyle bir de
dört harfı koyalım
kaya
arkadaşlar
yapmamız gereken
işlem şu
hatta şöyle yapalım
şimdi
beş harfı ya da
altı harfı
geç
bir ilerlettim
iteratörü
beş harfı
evet
bu iteratör
konumundakini
sileceğim
ama
silme fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değeri
silinen
öğeden
sonraki
öğenin
konumu
yani
benim
iteratörümün
emrağı
gösterdiği
noktada
bu iteratör
konumundaki
öğeyi
konteynerdan
çıkarttığım
zaman
geri dönüş
değerini
tekrar
aynı
iteratör
değişkenine
atarsam
onun değeri
zaten
kaya olacak
şimdi buna da
bakmam lazım
dört mü beş mi
beş mi
altı mı
hayır
arttır
efendim
sil
bu silindi
denizi gösteriyordu
sil
ama değerini
bir sonraki öğenin
konumu yaptı
ama
tabii ki bu durumda
iteratörü bir daha
arttırmayacaksın
zaten
bir sonraki öğeyi
gösteriyor
altı
buraya özellikle
dikkat
bu konuma
ekledim
ekleme fonksiyonları
geri dönüş
değeri olarak
ne döndürüyordu
eklenmiş
öğeye iteratör
dolayısıyla
bakın
en kritik yer
burası
buraya
necati'yi
eklediğimde
durum şöyle olacak
bir necati daha
geldi
ama
iteratörümün
değeri
arkadaşlar
eklenmiş olan
necati'ye
iteratör
geri dönüş
değerini
aynı iteratör
değişkenine
atarsam
peki şimdi
ne yapmam
lazım
iteratörü
kaç arttırmam
lazım
cevap
bir değil
iki arttırmam
lazım
öyle değil mi
şimdi iteratörü
iki arttıracağım
aytaçı
sildim
iteratör feride'yi
gösteriyor
hale geldi
feride'den
bir tane
ekledim
iteratörü
iki arttırdım
böylece
tamamladım
hadi şimdi
beraber kodu
yazalım
arkadaşlar
oto iter
eşittir
svekin
digini
while
iter
eşit
olmadığı
sürece
svekin
endi
arkadaşlar
if
iter
ok
length
bunu bir değişkende de tutabilirim
bu count
pure function olduğu için
zaten derleyici
optimizasyon yapıyor
o yüzden değişken
kullanmıyorum
if iter
ok length
eşit eşit
beş
buraya dikkat
iter eşittir
svekin
ereizi
iter
bakın o iteratör konumundakini
sildim ama
ereizin geri dönüş
değerini tekrar
aynı iteratörde
tuttum
şimdi iteratöre
arttıracak mıyım
cevap
hayır
real location
olması bir şeyi
değiştirmiyor
Alihan
çünkü real location
olsa da
ben
insert'ün
geri dönüş
değerini
kullanıyorum
insert'ün geri dönüş
değeri
real location
olsa da
yine
real location
daha sonraki
doğru konum
else if
iter ok
length
eşit eşit
şimdi buraya dikkat
iter
eşittir
svekin
insert'ü
iter
arkadaşlar
ve
söyleyin
yıldız
iter
ama
artı eşit
farklı şekle de yazabilirsiniz
önemli olan
else
o zaman
artı artı
iter
işte bu kadar
bu kadar
yanlış
yanlış bir şey
yazmışım
yok yanlış
görünmüyor
evet
bakın şimdi
papatya
nurullah
bunlar
8 ve
cahit gitti
tufan gitti
handan
andan
bir tane daha
eklendi
tekin gitti
su duruyor
arkadaşlar
aynin gitti
beş harfli
azmi
ayla
cemile'den
bir tane daha
koyduk cemile cemile
garo
fahri
gitti
yurdagül
ceyhun
aynin gitti
poyraz
papatya
candan
ve felin
gitti
gayet güzel
çalışıyor
değil mi
evet
o zaman
devam
değerli arkadaşlar
ve
hemen
bir sonraki
konteynerımıza
geçiyoruz
arkadaşlar
list
konteynerı
stood list
arkadaşlar
şimdi normalde
aslında
standart
liste
demiyor ki
bu
double link list
veri yapısı
ama
standartın
söylediklerine
bakarsanız
implementasyonlar
hemen
hepsi
hiç ben
aykırı bir durum
görmedim
hepsi
çifte bağlı
liste
veri yapısı
o yüzden
şimdi
çifte bağlı
liste
double link
list veri yapısını
genel olarak
link list nedir
efendim
singly link list nedir
double link list nedir
bunları
biliyor olmanız
gerekiyor
yani
c++
ile ilgili değil
hangi programlama
dilinde
kod yazarsanız
yazın
arkadaşlar
çok kısa
hemen hatırlatalım
şimdi
çifte bağlı liste
veri yapısı
yani
double link list
aslında
şuraya
şöyle yazın
arkadaşlar
double link list
yine
düğümler
düğüm temelli
bir veri yapısı
düğümlerin içinde
şöyle gösterelim
bir data var
ve
iki tane de
pointer var
pointerlardan biri
şu pointerlardan biri
olsun
arkadaşlar
kendisinden
sonra gelen
datayı tutan
düğümü gösteriyor
diğer pointer ise
önceki
datayı
tutan düğümü
gösteriyor
böylece
biz
arkadaşlar
bir
çifte bağlı
listede
bir düğümü
kullandığımız zaman
bu düğümdeki
datayı
kullanabiliyoruz
bu düğümün
içindeki
pointerlardan
birini
kullanarak
bir sonraki
düğüme
erişebiliyoruz
diğer pointerı
kullanarak da
bir önceki düğüme
erişebiliyoruz
şimdi
bak
en son söyleyeceğimi
en başta söyleyeyim
arkadaşlar
özellikle
bu son
15 senede
yaşanan gelişmeler
donanım tarafında
ve yazılım tarafında
bağlı listeleri
ister tekte bağlı liste olsun
ister çifte bağlı liste olsun
vektöre göre
avantajlı olması gereken
yerde bile
çoğunlukla
dezavantajlı hale getiriyor
yani bu
bağlı listeler artık
hiç kullanılmıyor
anlamına gelmesin
ama özellikle
konteynerda tutulan
öğe sayısı
belirli bir
değerin altındaysa
tipik olarak
bağlı listenin
avantaj sağladığı
sözde yerlerde
dahi
vektör
bağlı listeye
karşı
daha
avantajlı
daha hızlı
yani
İngilizce
tabiriyle
vektör
çoğu zaman
bağlı listenin
link listin
avantajlı
teorik olarak
avantajlı olması
gereken yerde
algoritmik karmaşıklığı
daha düşük olan
operasyonlarda
dahi
bağlı listeyi
outperform ediyor
şimdi aslında
şu bizim dersimizin
kapsamında
olmaması lazım
efendim
bağlı listelerin
avantajı ne
dezavantajı ne
çünkü bu konuda
en az 2 saat
3 saat
konuşabiliriz
arkadaşlar
bağlı liste
ne anlam veriyor
link list
İngilizcesini
soruyorsunuz herhalde
Nazım
link list
evet
şöyle İngilizce
terimler
link list
bağlı liste
bunların çeşitleri var
veri yapıları olarak
double link list
single link list
rotating link list
gibi
şimdi aslında
çifte bağlı liste ile
tekli bağlı liste
arasındaki fark
hemen onu da
konuşalım
eğer çifte bağlı liste
değil de
tekli bağlı liste
olsaydı
düğümlerde
bir tane pointer
olacaktı
bu da
arkadaşlar
çift yönde
hareket olanağı
olmayacaktı
sadece tek yönde
hareket edebilecekti
arkadaşlar
normalde
bağlı listenin
avantajı ve dezavantajı
teorik olarak
şöyle
ama tabii
pratikte
ayrıca konuşmamız
gerekiyor
bağlı listenin
avantajı
nerede
yani
kağıt üstünde
en azından
avantajı
nerede
ekleme ve
silme işlemleri
bilinen bir
konumdan
yapılıyorsa
o zaman
constant time
yani örneğin
bizim bağlı listemizdeki
veriler şöyle olsa
düğümdeki verileri
göstermiyor
bu ilk düğüm
arkadaşlar
efendim
ilk düğümün
içindeki
next pointer'ını
gösteriyorum
sadece
next pointer'ı
bu düğümü
gösteriyor
bunun next pointer'ı
bu düğümü
gösteriyor
bunun next pointer'ı
bu düğümü
gösteriyor
bunun next pointer'ı
null pointer
bunların içindeki
prev pointer'ları
bir önceki
veri ilişkin
düğümü gösteriyor
böyle bir
veri yapısından
bahsediyoruz
tabii ki
burada
ben bunları
C kursunda
ayrıntılı anlatıyorum
her düğüm
eklendiğinde
her yeni
ekleme işlemi
yapıldığında
unutmayın ki
bir node
allocate edilecek
bunun ciddi
bir maniyeti var
her silme
işleminde de
o node
de allocate
edilecek
yani
vektör gibi değil
vektör de tamam
contiguous memory
büyük bir
bellek bloğuna
ihtiyacınız olabilir
ama arkadaşlar
orası yettiği sürece
ve allocation
de allocation
yok
ama bağlı listeye
her ekleme
yaptığınızda
bir düğümü
allocate
etmeniz gerekiyor
dolayısıyla
hem allocation
maliyeti
çok yüksek
hem de
arkadaşlar
özellikle
data
size of'ça
küçükse
bellek maliyeti
çok artıyor
mesela
intleri
çifte bağlı
listede
double int
liste tutarken
size of int
size of pointer
tipik olarak
eşit olsun
arkadaşlar
vektörde
tutsak
4 byte yer
kaplayacak
bağlı listede
tuttuğumuzda
12 byte
olacak
çünkü 4 byte
artı
2 pointer
bir de
biliyorsunuz
her allocation
size verilenin
dışında
ayrı bir
sistemin
kendi kullandığı
bir header
kısmı da var
yani
bellek kullanımı
açısından
arkadaşlar
bağlı listeler
tam bir felaket
her düğüm için
bir allocation
olması
çifte bağlı liste ise
düğümün içinde
iki tane pointer
olması
her silme
işleminde
bunların ayrı ayrı
notların
de allocate
ediliyor
olması
bellek açısından
tam bir felaket
belki
bellek kullanımı
açısından
bir tane
özür dilerim
olumlu senaryo var
o da
fragmentation
ne olduğunu
bildiğinizi
varsayıyorum
benliğin fragmente
olması
arkadaşlar
mesela
diyelim ki
ben
50 bin tane
inti
bir sistemde
heapte
dinamik dizi
olarak tutmak
istersem
size of
int çarpı
50 bin
kadar
bitelik
minimal bir
bloğa
ihtiyacım var
bellekte o kadar
yer olabilir
ama
ardışık
bellek
bloğu
olmayabilir
işte buna
fragmentation
deniyor
ister istemez
heap alanı
farklı amaçlarla
kullanıldığı için
fragmente
olmak eğiliminde
dolayısıyla
fragmentasyon
nedeniyle
örneğin
vektör
veri yapısını
belirli bir
boyuttan sonra
büyütemeyebilirim
ilgili sistemde
ama
bağlı listede
evet
allocation
maniyeti
yüksek
ama diyelim ki
benim bir
nodum
çifte bağlı
listede
12 byte ise
12 byte
allocate edebildiğim
sürece
listeyi
büyütebilirim
ink tutuyorsa
liste
efendim
yine
tekli bağlı
liste
olsaydı
o da işte
forward list
STL'de
bunda da
bir öğe
için
8 byte
bir yere
ihtiyacım var
8 byte
ink tutuyorsa
allocate edebildiğim
sürece
listeyi
büyütebiliyorum
çifte bağlı
listede
çift yönde
hareket edebiliyorum
tekli bağlı
listede
sadece
tek yönde
hareket edebiliyorum
bağlı
listenin
avantaj
sağlayabileceği
seraryolar
şunlar
yani
bunlardan biri
söz konusu
değilse
zaten
bağlı listeyi
hiçbir şekilde
düşünmeyin
arkadaşlar
bir
indeksle
erişim
sık yapılan
bir işlem
olmayacak
çünkü
bağlı listede
indeksle
erişim
linear
kompleksti
yani
örneğin
10 bin tane
üye varsa
siz
5 bininci
üyenin
konumunu
daha önce
bir yerde
tutmadıysanız
o zaman
birinciden
ikinciye
ikinciden
üçüncüye
öyle öyle
dolaşacaksınız
dolayısıyla
indeksle
erişim
sık yapılan
bir işlem
değilse
arkadaşlar
constant time'da
değil
linear
kompleksti
olduğu için
yani
on
karmaşıklığında
olduğu için
arkadaşlar
bağlı listede
hiç uygun
bir aday
değil
oysa
vektörde
hak diye
erişiyorum
değil mi
belirli bir
indeksteki
öğeğe
yani
sıra bilgisiyle
konum bilgisiyle
indeks bilgisiyle
erişim
vektörde
constant
verdi
burada
indeksle
erişim
söz konusuysa
zaten
vektörü
seçelim
yani
bağlı listeyi
düşünmem bile
arkadaşlar
değerli erişim
konusunda
ikisi de
sıralı
değilse
ikisi de
linear
kompleksti
yani
vektörde
olsa örneğin
19 bin
değerindeki
öğeğe
erişeceğim
int
tutan
bir
konteyner
vektörde
olsa
bakacağım
birinci mi
değil
ozan
ikinci mi
değil
listede
olsa
bakacağım
ikisi de
on
karmaşıklığında
vektörde
sadece
sondan
ekleme
constant
time'dayken
deck'de
sadece
sondan
ekleme
ve baştan
constant
time'dayken
algoritmanın
karmaşıklığı
olarak
computational
kompleksti
olarak
arkadaşlar
çifte
bağlı
listede
herhangi
bir konumdan
ekleme
yeter ki
ilgili
konum
elimde
olsun
constant
time
şimdi
düşünsenize
mesela
bu
burada
efendim
olsun
burada
ben
7'nin
konumuna
14'ü
eklemek
isteyeyim
aslında
yapmam gereken
işlem şu
yine bir
node
oluşturuyorum
node'un
datasını
veriyorum
şimdi bu
7'nin
konumuna
gelecek ya
18'i
tutan
düğümün
next'i
bunu gösterecek
efendim
7'yi
tutanın
previ
bunu gösterecek
14'ü
tutan
yeni
oluşturduğum
node'un
next'i
arkadaşlar
7'yi
gösterecek
bunun
previ de
18'i
gösterecek
bu ne
demek
sadece
pointer'ların
değerini
değiştiriyorum
yani
konumunu
bildiğim
yerden
bir
ekleme
işlemi
yaptığımda
container'daki
öğe sayısından
bağımsız
olarak
işlem
maliyeti
sabit
bu da
constant time
demek
aynı şekilde
konumunu
bildiğim
öğeyi
belirli bir
konumdaki
öğeyi
silmek de
böyle
ama tabi
o konumun
elimde olması
gerekiyor
yani şu
değil
3612'yi
sil
bu constant time
değil tabi ki
ama
elimde
3612'yi
tutan
konum varsa
daha son derece
basit
ne yapacağım
arkadaşlar
bunun
adresini
bu düğümün adresini
bir değişkende
tutacağım
sonra
bunun next'i
bunu gösteriyordu ya
bunu gösterecek
bunun
previ de
bunu gösteriyordu ya
bunu gösterecek
öyle değil mi
bunu da
free edeceğim
bu kadar
işte gördüğümüz gibi
çifte bağlı
listenin
W link
listinin
asıl
görünürde
olmayan
ama
teorik
avantajı
konumunu
bildiğimiz
yerden
ekleme
ya da silme
işleminin
sadece
sondan
ya da
baştan
değil
neresi
olursa olsun
custom
time
olması
beklenen
avantaj bu
yani bu şu
demek
aslında
teorik olarak
bakarsanız
sık sık
konumunu
bildiğim yerlerden
baş ve son
da değil
ekleme
silme
işlemleri
yapıyorsam
konumunu
bulmak
o en miydi
tabii ki
arkadaşlar
yani
birerli bir konumdaki
o en
karmaşıklığında
o zaman
constant time
da dedik
konumunu
bildiğimiz
yerden
ekleme
ve silme
işlemi
yapmak
bunun dışında
neden
bağlı liste
kullanmak
söz konusu
olabilir
bakın
burada bile
şöyle diyorum
bağlı liste
kullanım demiyorum
söz konusu
olabilir
diyorum
bu söz
konusu
olan yerlerin
çoğunda da
daha sonradan
konuşacağımız
örneğin özellikle
bu
caching
mekanizmasıyla
ilgili faktörlerden
yine çoğunlukla
vektör
listeyi
outperform ediyor
ama en azından
orada belki
öğe sayısına bağlı
olarak bir profiling
yapmanızda
fayda olabilir
ama onun dışında
profiling yapmanıza bile
gerek yok
anlamında söylüyorum
bir ilginç
avantajı daha var
bu genelde
programcıların
dikkat etmediği
bir avantaj
şimdi bu
son cümleler olsun
bir dahaki
çarşamba günü
iki gün sonra
devam edeceğiz
arkadaşlar bakın
burada
genellikle programcılar
göz ardı ediyor
bu aslında
bağlı
listeyinin
bir avantajı
değil
not temelli
veri yapılarının
bir avantajı
şimdi
öyle algoritmalar
var ki
bu algoritmalar
swap yapıyor
mesela
sort algoritmaları
reverse
algoritması
arkadaşlar
merge
algoritmaları
unique
algoritması
yani
içinde
swap işlemi
geçen
hatta
bolca
swap işlemi
geçen
algoritmalar
var
şimdi konumuzun
swap ile ne alakası var
hemen oraya gelelim
arkadaşlar
vektörel veri
yapılarında
swap'ı
fiziksel olarak
implemente
etme dışında
başka bir yol
yok
mesela
vektörde
tutulan
elemanlar
arkadaşlar
500 byte
olsun
yani bu nesne
500 byte
bu nesne
kullandığı bir
kaynak falan da yok
net 500 byte
hani halk tabiriyle
kemiksiz
500 byte
arkadaşlar
herhangi bir
swap
gerektiren
algoritmayı
koşturduğunuzda
artık
şunun kaçarı yok
bu swap işlemi
nasıl yapılacak
e bunun
değerini
bunda tutacaksınız
buna
buna atacaksınız
500 değeri
değil bu arada
byte büyüklüğü
buna da
bundaki değeri
kopyalayacaksınız
öyle değil mi
buraya kadar
anlaşıldı mı
yani
vektörel veri
yapısında
swap'ta
blok kopyalamasından
kaçınma
maniyeti yok
şansı yok
ve blok
kopyalaması
yüksek
maliyetli bir
işlem
ama
şimdi
nodüler
bir veri
yapısını
düşünün
eğer bu
örneğin
liste olsaydı
bağlı liste
olsaydı
durum şöyle
olacaktı
bu 500
byte'lık
veri
bir düğümün
içinde
öyle değil mi
şöyle gösterelim
arkadaşlar
efendim
bu da
düğüm olsun
düğümün içinde
bu var
bir de
şunu açık
renk yapmalıymışım
düğümün içinde
bu var
data var
iki tane de
yine saydım
olmak
iki tane de
pointer var
o zaman
niye ben
datayı
swap edeyim ki
düğümün içindeki
pointer'ları
swap edebilirim
değil mi
bu da
swap maliyetini
azaltıyor
bu algoritmanın
karmaşıklığıyla
ilgili bir
konu değil
ama
pratiğe
yansıyor
yani siz
diyelim ki
500 byte'lık
blokları
100 bin
kere
swap etmek
kopyalamak
yerine
sadece
düğümün içindeki
pointer'ları
kopyalıyorsunuz
yani 500
pointer size
of'u
4 byte olsun
datanın
kendi size
of'u
500 byte olsun
çok ciddi bir
maliyet farkı
yaratıyor
o yüzden
swap yoğun
algoritmalarda
zaten bunu
şurada da
göreceğiz
bir dahaki
derste
listin
interfeisindeki
fonksiyonları
gördüğümüzde
tipik olarak
swap yoğun
algoritmalar
listin
kendi
üye
fonksiyonu
mesela listin
reverse fonksiyonu
var
geçen
derste de
bundan
bahsetmiştim
oysa
vektör için
doğrudan
reverse
algoritması
kullanıyorum
listin
neden
kendi
reverse fonksiyonu
var
çünkü
reverse ederken
notlardaki
dataları
takas etmek
için
datayı
swap etmiyor
notlardaki
pointer'ları
swap ediyor
evet maalesef
bugünkü dersimizde
burada sona eriyor
çarşamba
günü
tekrar görüşeceğiz
arkadaşlar
tutulan veriden
bağımsız
sadece pointer
kopyalama
maliyetiyle
evet evet
Alihan
tamamen onu
kastettim
şarşamba günü
görüşmek üzere
herkese iyi akşamlar
diliyorum
hoşçakalın
değerli arkadaşlar
abone ol